die Versorgung und Unterbringung der
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine gehen soll
und da sind wir schon beim Thema gerade
in diesen Minuten ist eine Debatte hier
im Deutschen Bundestag eröffnet worden
da geht es darum wie man sicherstellen
kann dass die Frauen die kommen die
Kinder die kommen die Jugendlichen den
kommen aus der Ukraine die
Kriegsflüchtlinge denn es sind zu 84
Prozent beispielsweise Frauen und
Mädchen die aus der Ukraine hierher
kommen und Schutz suchen und Unterkunft
suchen und hier soll debattiert werden
jetzt eben folgenden auf Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion ob man einen Masterplan
braucht für eine Hilfe für Sicherheit
und für Integration dieser Frauen Kinder
und Jugendlichen aus der Ukraine wir
hören mal rein es spricht lorothie
bärschnittlichen NGOs mit ehemaligen
Abgeordneten gehabt die uns nicht
sehnlicher bitten als wenn sie schon den
Frieden in Europa verteidigen dass wir
wenigstens hier unsere Hausaufgaben
machen wir haben es zugesagt bitte
machen sie das auch
[Applaus]
war das für die cdu/csu-fraktion die
diesen Antrag hier gestellt hat dies
diese Antrag ist Grundlage dieser
debatterien 13 konkrete Schritte hat die
Union hier vorgelegt und wir hören mal
was die SPD-Fraktion sagt die
Abgeordnete Ulrike Bahr
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kollegen Kolleginnen seid inzwischen
sechs Wochen folgen wir mit wachsendem
Entsetzen dem Horror des russischen
Angriffs auf die Ukraine inzwischen
befindet sich ein Viertel der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung auf der Flucht
etwa 300.000 Menschen zum allergrößten
Teil Frauen und Kinder haben in
Deutschland Aufnahme gefunden die
Hilfsbereitschaft in der
Zivilgesellschaft aber auch in den
Kommunen und bei den Wohlfahrtsverbänden
ist beeindruckend denn dieser Krieg ist
nicht nur geografisch nahm er ist auch
emotional sehr nah an uns dran
2018 hat eine Stipendiatin des
internationalen parlamentarischen
Stipendiums aus Kiew drei Monate in
meinem Bundestagsbüro gearbeitet zum
Abschluss im Sommer 2018 hat ihre ganze
Familie mich im Bundestag besucht
katharina hat anschließend in
Deutschland Arbeit gefunden jetzt hat
sie ihre Großmutter Mutter und die
kleine Schwester zu sich nach Berlin
geholt vor zwei Tagen berichtete sie
entsetzt über die Massaker
die Familien hat ja eine Datsche kurz
hinter Rutscher und fragt sich jetzt ob
die ehemaligen Nachbarn noch leben ob
Sie Ihren Garten je wiedersehen können
in dieser emotionalen Ausnahmesituation
möchten Katharinas Angehörige nicht
verteilt werden sondern brauchen ihre
Tochter Enkelin und Schwester als
Stabilitätsanker und Orientierungshilfe
und möchten darum in Berlin bleiben das
ist wohl für jeden überaus
nachvollziehbar
Zeuge solche niedrigschwelligen Zugänge
die unproblematische Einreise und der
visumsfrei Aufenthalt für 90 Tage treten
gelegentlich in Konflikt mit der
unverzüglichen Registrierung unsere
innenministerinnen sie Faser arbeitet
seit Wochen an der Verbesserung der
Registrierung
Bundespolizei geht regelhaft durch die
Züge kontrolliert die ukrainischen Pässe
und macht auch die Registrierung und die
damit verbundenen Vorteile aufmerksam
die Ausländerbehörden vor Ort werden von
Bundesinnenministerium im Einsatz von
pickstationen unterstützt die einen
Abgleich mit europäischen Datenbanken
ermöglichen nur über die Registrierung
gibt es eine Zugang zu Leistungen zum
längerfristigen Aufenthaltsrecht und zu
einer Arbeitserlaubnis an Ankunft
Hotspots wie den Berliner Hauptbahnhof
weisen die Helferinnen und Helfer sowohl
auf die Registrierung als auch auf das
auf die Gefahren private Angebote hin
denn Schutz kann nur funktionieren wenn
wir wissen wer gekommen ist und Schutz
braucht
die meisten geflüchteten lassen sie auch
zeitnah registrieren nach meiner
Wahrnehmung läuft sehr vieles inzwischen
sehr gut und koordiniert denn wir können
auf Erfahrungen und Strukturen aufbauen
die es seit 2015 gibt und die Bund und
Länder gemeinsam fort entwickelt und
verbessert haben die Bund Länder
Zusammenarbeit zur wohl im innenresort
als auch im Bereich Frauen und Familie
ist eng abgestimmt richtig so die
schnelle
die schnelle humanitäre Hilfe unter
Schutz für geflüchtete Menschen aus der
Ukraine ist kein gutes Feld für
parteipolitische Profilierung hier
müssen wir auf allen Ebenen Bund Länder
Kommunen zusammenhelfen und tun das auch
eine befreundete Jugendamtsleiterin aus
bayerisch Schwaben hat mir berichtet
dass all die Integrationsmaßnahmen die
der Antrag der Union auflistet
okay in ihrer Kommune bereits umgesetzt
werden parallel zu Sprachkursen gibt es
Spielgruppen für Kinder unter sechs
Jahren Schwangere und Wöchnerinnen in
den Unterkünften werden von
Familienhebammen betreut die
Bundesanstalt für Arbeit bietet
regelmäßig Sprechstunden und Beratung in
den Unterkünften an
die 2016 gemeinsam mit UNICEF
entwickelten Schutzkonzepte für
gemeinschaftsunterkünfte werden
selbstverständlich angewendet auch die
zentralen Bundesprogramme zur
Integrationsförderung wird meine
Kollegin noch eingehen auch das bmfj hat
viele seine zentralen Informationen zur
Beratungsdienste mit Blick auf die
ukrainischen Frauen und Jugendlichen
erweitert so zum Beispiel die
hilfe-telefone Gewalt gegen Frauen und
Schwangere in Not ein Angebot in
russischer Sprache gibt es bereits und
Dolmetscher Angebote auf Ukrainisch sind
den Vorbereitungen der bundesweite
Koordinierungskreis gegen
Menschenhandel Kock e.V ist Partner bei
der Schulung von Bundespolizei Bundesamt
für Migration und Flüchtlinge und von
Hilfsorganisationen und Ministerin
Spiegel hat gestern aus einem Briefing
vom Anfang dieser Woche mit dem cock
berichtet das Hinweisen auf Missbrauch
Ausbeutung und Zwangsprostitution sehr
sorgfältig gegangen wird und besonders
froh bin ich dass es seit Ende letzter
Woche eine bundesweite Koordinierung zur
Versorgung Unterbringung und Verteilung
von Kindern und Jugendlichen gibt die
aus evakuierten ukrainischen
Kinderheimen mit ihren Gruppen und ihren
Betreuerinnen kommen
[Applaus]
Spion mit dem so
s-
Kapazitäten melden die Verteilung wird
dann vom Bundesverwaltungsamt gesteuert
und natürlich bleiben noch viele Fragen
offen Vormundschaft und Sorgerecht für
die Betroffenen Minderjährigen nach
ukrainischem recht sind oft nicht
geklärt
Qualitätsstandards nach deutschem
jugendhilferecht können übergangsweise
nicht garantiert werden hier brauchen
wir schnell geprüfte Informationen und
pragmatische Übergangslösungen um auch
den deutschen einrichtungsträgern
rechtssicheres Handel zu ermöglichen und
sie in ihrem Engagement nicht den
Konflikt mit der Heimaufsicht zu bringen
für die Finanzierung von Hilfen zum
Beispiel auch für Menschen mit
Behinderungen die ebenfalls in
nennenswerter Zahl kommen und dringend
Unterstützung brauchen hoffe ich sehr
auf eine schnelle Einigung bei der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute
Nachmittag es ist sehr gut dass es für
solche umfassende Hilfe einen sehr
breiten Konsens über die Fraktionen
hinweg gibt ganz besonderer Dank gebührt
aber der Zivilgesellschaft in meinem
Wahlkreis Augsburg gibt es eine recht
große ukrainische Community und einen
sehr aktiven ukrainischen Verein der
sich mit viel Herzblut und Engagement
für die Landsleute einsetzt und dabei
sehr viel Unterstützung und Hilfe in der
gesamten Stadtgesellschaft findet das
erlebe ich auch anders wo genau so die
Deutsche Stiftung für Engagement und
Ehrenamt vernetzt dieses großartige
zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement für
die Ukraine im Bündnis Allahs Ukraine
kommt zu Ende bleibt zu hoffen dass uns
allen bei diesem Marathon nicht die
Puste ausgeht die Menschen aus und in
der Ukraine brauchen unsere Solidarität
noch lange vielen Dank
die Hilfsbereitschaft für ukrainische
geflüchtete in Deutschland ist groß
nicht jede Hilfe die angeboten wird ist
auch so gemeint EU-weit mehren sich
Berichte von Menschenhandel auch von
sexuellen Missbrauch von ukrainischen
Frauen auch in Deutschland und Politik
und Flüchtlingsorganisationen sind
alarmiert und
verschiedene Maßnahmen dagegen sind
ergriffen worden bzw
das ganze muss natürlich beobachtet
werden Gottfried kurio jetzt in der
Aussprache hier von der AFD den wir
jetzt hören
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte bisschen ändern meine Damen
und Herren die vielen pseudo-flüchtlinge
von 2015 Männer ohne ihre Familien ohne
Pässe ohne dann ohne Rückkehr wählen sie
waren das was sie waren jetzt lernt
Deutschland wahre Flüchtlinge kennen
Frauen und Kinder mit Pässen dankbarer
rückkehrwillig so unterscheidet sich
diese Flucht von der Migrationswelle
2015 in allem fundamental nur in einem
nicht wieder weigern sich die politisch
Zustände in die Lage zu kontrollieren
und zu erfassen die allseitige
Unterstützung der ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge ist ja fraglos effektive
Hilfe funktioniert aber nur wenn die
Helfer die Kontrolle haben über das was
sie tun
deutsche Sicherheitsbehörden warnen
Schleuser würden die erleichterten
Einreisebedingungen aktiv bewerben
gefälschte ukrainische Pässe im Umlauf
bringen deutschland stehe damit auch für
terroristische Gruppierungen offen die
Innenministerin aber nimmt trotz dieser
Warnungen Sicherheitsrisiken für
Deutschland sehenden Auges in Kauf das
kann nicht sein meine Damen und Herren
was ist jetzt braucht ist lückenlose
Registrierung Prüfung der
Personaldokumente Erfassung der
Identität Verhinderung von
Trittbrettfahrern die sich als Ukraine
ausgeben oder im Strom der Flüchtlinge
mit einreisen um hier Asyl zu beantragen
die Ukraine ist kein Land afrikanischer
Austauschstudenten nur eine vollständige
Registrierung macht eine gute
Organisation der Versorgung und eine
belastungsgerechte Verteilung möglich
aber die Innenministerin verweigert die
Registrierung ausdrücklich so werden im
Schatten einer echten flüchtlingskrise
unberechtigte hierher gelockt ideal um
die Statistiken über illegale Migranten
zu bereinen indem man sie im breiten
Strom einer echten humanitären
Zuwanderung die unregistriert läuft
Untertauchen lässt meine Damen und
Herren 2015 war kein Kontrollverlust es
war eine bewusste kontrollverweigerung
und jetzt droht sie sich zu wiederholen
haben Sie denn nichts gelernt übrigens
so wie die illegale Migration jetzt in
den Ukraine Flüchtlingen versteckt
werden so soll jetzt der gesamte
Missmanagement dieser Regierung als
kriegsfolge vertuscht werden so sollen
die schon im Februar vor Kriegsbeginn
explodierten Energiepreise und die
Inflation auf kriegsverursacht
umgedeutet werden dabei stecken da vor
allem drin
uferloses Drucken von EZB-Geld für
eu-schulden starten
CO2-Besteuerung was tatsächlich hinzu
kam waren die hausgemachten Sanktionen
die uns selbst erheblich schaden das ist
diese Regierung sich besinnungs ethisch
in die Brust werfen aber Schaden vom
deutschen Volk abwenden Fehlanzeige
meine Damen und Herren was ist noch
notwendig nicht Ukrainer die jetzt mit
ankommen müssen wie die massenzustrom
Richtlinie vorsieht in ihr Heimatland
zurück das alte hunderttausende her die
sich nach wie vor auf Steuerzahlerkosten
in Deutschland Wohlergehen lassen die
300.000 vollziehbar Ausreisepflicht in
Ausländer setzt erhebliche Ressourcen
frei bei Unterbringung im Bildungswesen
bei der Staatsfinanzierung und bitte
rückführen rückführen rückführen
nationaler Kraftanstrengung nie
umgesetzt reine Propaganda Parolen
werden diesmal nicht reichen und
spätestens jetzt muss doch Schluss sein
mit noch zusätzlichen globalistischen
umsiedlungs- und resettlement-
wichtig die Flüchtlinge selbst wollen
nach Ende der Kämpfe zurück die Ukraine
brauchten nicht den Zynismus von
Arbeitsminister Heil der hiesigen
Fachkräftemangel durch Ukraine decken
will sie werden sehr bald in ihrer
Heimat gebraucht und die Ukraine wünscht
deshalb Unterricht nach ukrainischen
Lehrplänen aber keine schulische
Integration nach Deutschland der
Unterricht in der Ukraine sei intensiver
mit höheren Anforderungen in kürzerer
Zeit außerdem könne heißt es von Seiten
der Ukraine in
Integrationsklassen die eigene nationale
Identität Schaden nehmen lieber
Altparteien Politiker wertvolle Hinweise
man legt dort Wert auf Unterricht mit
Niveau statt Absenkung zur
Verschleierung der Probleme durch
sprachfremde Schüler und für alle die
jetzt gelb-blaue Fahnen schwenken aber
bestimmt nie die deutschen Farben man
legt dort Wert auf nationale Identität
und ihre Wahrung ich danke Ihnen
war das von der AFD sie sehen der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat seine
Tasche hier gepackt auf der
Regierungsbank und verlässt den
Plenarsaal denn es trifft sich ja heute
die Bund Länder Runde da geht es unter
anderem darum wie Menschen die aus der
Ukraine hierher nach Deutschland
geflüchtet sind gut versorgt werden
können gut untergebracht werden können
wie sich Bund Länder und Kommunen auch
die Kosten teilen um das Ganze auch zu
gewährleisten jetzt können wir die
Bundesfamilienministerin Anne Spiegel
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren Abgeordnete Liebe
zuhörende es ist nun fünf Wochen her
dass dieser schreckliche
Angriffskrieg von Putin in der Ukraine
gestartet hat und sechs Wochen pardon es
ist es sind schreckliche Bilder die uns
tagtäglich erreichen und die uns alle
fassungslos machen aber sie machen uns
nicht tatenlos wir handeln als
Bundesregierung und das von Anfang an
wir stehen zusammen und wir arbeiten
daran dass wir die zu uns fliehenden
Frauen und Kinder aus der Ukraine vom
ersten Tag an gut aufnehmen können
unzählige haben sich auch ehrenamtlich
engagiert tun das nach wie vor haben
auch private Unterkünfte angeboten und
für diese wirklich großartige
Hilfsbereitschaft der vielen
Ehrenamtlichen in der Bundesrepublik die
das Ankommen der Menschen die
Schreckliches und dramatisches erlebt
haben erleichtert möchte ich mich an
dieser Stelle ganz ganz herzlich
bedanken
ich hatte gestern im zuständigen
Ausschuss auch ausführlich berichtet was
wir auch in der Bundesregierung machen
um die ukrainischen Frauen und Kinder
gut aufnehmen zu können ich möchte hier
auch auf einige Punkte eingehen die sehr
wichtig sind zum einen gibt es die
bundesweite Koordinierung für die
Aufnahme ukrainischer weisenheime und
ihrer Betreuerinnen und Betreuer dann
ist es ist sehr wichtig dass wir diese
Kinder die in ihrem jungen Leben schon
so viel durchgemacht haben die
dramatisches im Krieg und auf der Flucht
erlebt haben dass wir sie als Gruppe
zusammen behalten können mit ihren
Betreuerinnen und Betreuern und deswegen
gibt es zwei Säulen es gibt die SOS
Meldestelle dankenswerterweise auch dank
des großartigen Engagements der
SOS-Kinderdörfer ins Leben gerufen hier
können Kapazitäten für Unterkünfte für
Waisenheime gemeldet werden und dann
erfolgt und das ist die zweite Säule
über das Bundesverwaltungsamt die auch
Aufteilung nach dem königssteiner
Schlüssel auf die Länder und ich möchte
an dieser Stelle auch ausdrücklich
betonen es gibt ein gemeinsames
unaufgeregtes und entschlossenes Handeln
von Bund Länder und Kommunen an dieser
Stelle und das ist auch richtig und der
gemeinsame Maßstab unseres Handels das
ist der Kinderschutz und das ist das
Kindeswohl an dieser Stelle
des Weiteren gibt es natürlich den
Schutz die Prävention der Frauen vom
Menschenhandel und Zwangsprostitution
und ich bin sehr froh zu wissen dass die
Strukturen die damals aufgebaut wurden
in den Jahren 2015 und fortfolgende beim
Bundeskriminalamt bei der Bundespolizei
bei dem LKA aber auch beim cock dem
bundesweiten Koordinierungskreis gegen
Menschenhandel dass diese Strukturen
ineinandergreifen zum Schutz der Frauen
dass man vor Ort präsent ist und auch
dafür sorgt dass es eben dazu nicht
kommt aber ich möchte auch betonen dass
es zum Glück nur Einzelfälle sind es
sind zum Glück nur Einzelfälle aber gut
dass man hier genau hinschaut und auch
sensibilisiert ist und
selbstverständlich die hilfe-telefone
die Beratungsstellen alles was wir auch
hier an Infrastruktur haben für von
Gewalt betroffene Frauen oder Frauen in
schwierigen Situationen Schwangere in
Not und anderes die sind natürlich auch
für die ukrainischen Vertrauen da und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir hier
jetzt auch über Dolmetscherinnen und
Dolmetscher diese Angebote entsprechend
sprachlich auch zugänglich machen
ich komme
zu einem weiteren Punkt
der ein ganz besonders wichtiger ist und
wo wir auch in der Bundesrepublik eine
Verantwortung ja eine Verpflichtung
haben und das ist die Evakuierung von
Holocaust Überlebenden aus der Ukraine
dank des großen Engagements der durch
claim clames conference ist es unter
anderem gelungen dass gestern 47
Holocaust Überlebende in die
Bundesrepublik gebracht werden konnten
das sind sehr schwierige Evakuierungen
denn die Menschen sind hochbetagt sie
sind teils schwerst pflegebedürftig aber
es ist wichtig dass wir hier auch zu der
Verantwortung und Verpflichtung stehen
diese Menschen gemeinsam gut aufnehmen
zu können
und selbstverständlich stärken wir die
vielen ehrenamtlichen die jetzt aktiv
sind nicht nur an den Bahnhöfen und den
ankunftspunkten nein auch bei den
tagtäglichen ersten Schritten der
Integration sind Sie da und stehen den
ukrainischen Frauen und Kindern zur
Seite und da möchte ich exemplarisch
nennen die Deutsche Stiftung für
Engagement und Ehrenamt die vom ersten
Tag an sofort aktiv war und alles daran
gesetzt hat hier auch die entsprechenden
Strukturen bereitzustellen und
Organisationen wie etwa Menschen stärken
Menschen wo über Patenschaften die
ersten Schritte der Integration Hand in
Hand gemeinsam gegangen werden das neben
vielen weiteren tollen Aktivitäten damit
die ukrainischen Menschen hier gut
ankommen können und dazu gehört eben
auch der schnelle Zugang zu
Integrationskursen zu Sprachkursen und
selbstverständlich tun wir was und
selbstverständlich werden wir das auch
weiter auf damit eben der Spracherwerb
aber auch der Zugang zum Arbeitsmarkt
jetzt schnell vorangehen kann
exemplarisch möchte ich hier nennen Mami
lernt Deutsch ein Sprachkurs des
Familienministeriums der dafür sorgt
dass auch nebenbei dann neben dem
deutschlern für die Mütter auch die
Kinderbetreuung für die Kleinen mit
dabei ist meine
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich
möchte abschließend sagen dass ich in
den nächsten Tagen nach Polen reisen
werde es ist mir eine sehr wichtige
Reise gemeinsam mit deutschen
Kinderschutzorganisation ich treffe dort
unter anderem die polnische
Familienministerin und es ist wichtig
dass wir auch international in der
Europäischen Union hier zusammenstehen
und uns gemeinsam diese Herausforderung
annehmen damit die Menschen die
schreckliches durchgemacht haben und es
sind überwiegend Frauen und Kinder die
hier auf der Flucht sind damit die
Menschen gut aufgenommen werden können
damit Sie selbstverständlich auch eine
psychosoziale Versorgung bekommen das
ist auch in den Strukturen des Ankommens
natürlich mit drin und damit vor allen
Dingen die Kinder die traumatisiert sind
zum Teil die schreckliches durchgemacht
haben damit diese Kinder wieder Kinder
sein können das sollte unser aller
Anstrengung wert sein danke
die Bundesfamilienministerin an der
Spiegel hier zu dem Antrag der
cdu/cs-fraktion
also der politische Wille beispielsweise
auch schnellen Zugang zu
Integrationskursen zu Sprachkursen zu
ermöglichen
ist
bei allen hier sehr deutlich und
sichtbar das muss natürlich dann auch
noch umgesetzt werden und
dazu auch muss das nötige Geld
bereitstehen
Klara Bünger jetzt für die Linke
sehr geehrte Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Frau Ministerin Spiegel liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Union
gefällt sich ganz offensichtlich darin
die Aufnahme von geflüchteten aus der
Ukraine unter dem Label Sicherheit und
Ordnung zu thematisieren wenn Sie jetzt
noch einen Masterplan fordern dann lässt
das aus meiner Sicht nichts Gutes
erahnen denn unter dieser anmaßenden
Überschrift hatte Ex-Innenminister
Seehofer zahlreiche Verschärfungen im
Umgang mit Suchenden propagiert als
Juristin sage ich Ihnen Frau Bär
rechtlich gibt es momentan keine
Möglichkeit eine systematische
Registrierung der geflüchteten aus der
Ukraine zu erzwingen solange sie keine
staatlichen Leistungen und keinen
Aufenthaltstitel beantragen bis zum 23
mai können sie sich legal in Deutschland
aufhalten und dass die übergangs-
sehr viele geflüchtete können derzeit
privat bei Bekannten und Verwandten
unterkommen das ist doch positiv und
sollte im Übrigen auch für andere
geflüchteten Gruppen ermöglicht werden
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage
[Applaus]
geflüchtete Frauen und Kinder
Fluktuation in den Lagern und
Massenunterkünften sprechen denn dort
sind die Frauen sexuellen Übergriffen
meist schutzlos ausgeliefert das sagt
übrigens auch das BKA im Innenausschuss
und die Täter sind nicht nur Ehemänner
männliche Verwandte oder Mitbewohner
sondern sicherheitsdienstmitarbeiter
Sozialarbeiter Hausmeister also Personen
die dort im staatlichen Auftrag tätig
sind und was lernen wir daraus
staatliche Kontrolle ist nicht
gleichbedeutend mit Schutz für Frauen
der beste Schutz für Frauen und Kinder
wäre es sie nicht in massenunterkünfte
und ankerzentren zu stecken wie es aber
die Union seit Jahren für Abschreckung
propagiert sondern auf dezentrale
Unterbringung zu setzen als sie in der
letzten Legislaturperiode und ich
erinnere mich eine Verschärfung nach der
nächsten im Flüchtlingsrecht hier durch
den Bundestag gejagt haben hat sie die
Sicherheit von Frauen herzlich wenig
interessiert
und vor diesem Hintergrund wird ihre
Antrag feuchtnerisch und aus meiner
Sicht auch peinlich die Union fordert
ein hilfsgipfel wir denken auch dass es
ein flüchtlingsgipfel braucht um von
Anfang an gute gute Abstimmung von Bund
Ländern und Kommunen mit
zivilgesellschaftlichen Akteuren und
Fachverbänden zu gewährleisten denn
Fachverbände wissen am besten über
praktische Probleme Bescheid und ihre
Kompetenz muss der Entwicklung kurz aber
Mittel und langfristiger Maßnahmen
genutzt werden ich war diese Woche im
ankunftszentrum mit meiner Kollegin
Petra Pau in Tegel das ankunftszentrum
ist das erste Zentrum deutschlandweit in
dem Berliner Hilfsorganisation zusammen
unter einem Dach arbeiten und das ist
schon mal gut weil Dinge so besser
koordiniert werden können denn es kommen
mittlerweile sehr viele Menschen an
besonders vulnerablergruppen darunter
auch Menschen mit Kriegsverletzungen
eine Mutter ist dort mit ihrem
Kriegsverletzten Sohn der sehr schnell
in ein Krankenhaus gebracht werden
musste angekommen dank der guten
Zusammenarbeit konnte die Versorgung des
Kindes professionell und schnell
koordiniert werden das ist gut und und
sollte eine Vorbildfunktion haben
und dennoch gibt es sehr viele
Baustellen immer noch müssen
Schutzlücken geschlossen werden es muss
sichergestellt werden dass alle die aus
der Ukraine geflohen sind geschützt
werden das heißt auch drittstadlerin und
insbesondere Studierende brauchen diese
Rechtssicherheit
wir müssen aber auch diejenigen schützen
die sich dem Kriegsdienst in Russland
verweigern und diejenigen die in
Russland gegen den Krieg protestieren
ich bekomme immer mehr Anfragen von
Menschen aus Russland die fliehen wollen
wir dürfen diese mutigen Menschen nicht
alleine lassen
und schließlich lassen Sie uns das
diskriminierende
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz endlich
aufheben wir wollen alle Schutzsuchenden
gleich behandeln und zwar menschenwürdig
vielen Dank
und sagt Clara Bünger die Sprecherin für
fluchtpolitik der
Linksfraktion erteile ich das Wort der
Kollegin Silke launert
bisschen Frage nicht zugelassen haben es
hätte genau zu dem Satz rechtlich gibt
es keine Möglichkeit diese
Identifizierung durchzuführen
Registrierung durchzuführen weil es
hätte genau dazu gepasst und dann hätten
die Nachfrage des ergänzt ich meine
Frage ist und damit haben sie recht wir
von Union hätten gerne eine
Registrierung möglichst Grenzen an
Feststellung wer alles im Land ist und
danach vielleicht sogar dort vor Ort
oder spätestens danach die Registrierung
meine Frage im Innenausschuss ob es denn
möglich ist das rechtlich zu ermöglichen
dass es geht also eine gesetzliche
Grundlage zu schaffen wofür wir als
Gesetzgeber auch zuständig sind entweder
national oder europarechtlich diese
Frage wurde ganz klar bejaht von der
innenstaatssekretärin und es ist auch so
man kann diese rechtliche Grundlage
schaffen und daher tut es mir leid dass
Sie hier so blenden und zu tun als geht
wer das rechtlich nicht möglich wir sind
dazu da so was zu schaffen wenn es
zweckmäßig ist und gerade bei großen
Zahlen ist es zweckmäßig können wir wohl
auch helfen aber es soll strukturiert
sein wir müssen wissen wie viele Kinder
da sind wenn die in die Schulen kommen
wir müssen uns vorbereiten deshalb ist
es echt schade dass sie hier so falsche
Auskünfte geben oder so Halbwahrheiten
sagen wir es mal so
Silke launert war das für die CDU tierse
Fraktionen also Sie haben es ja selber
irgendwie auch erkannt dass sie da
falsch liegen also sie haben gesagt sie
wollen gerne eine rechtliche Möglichkeit
dafür schaffen dass die Menschen
registriert werden ich habe die
tatsächlich rechtliche Lage beschrieben
wie sie ist das ist derzeit keinen Zwang
zur Registrierung gibt und ich denke das
sollte auch so bleiben
ja an den Grenzen gibt es keine festen
Kontrollen Menschen mit ukrainischen
Pass Düren
in der EU aufhalten
jetzt für die FDP geht die Jensen die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich freue mich
liebe Union dass sie in ihrem Antrag
familienpolitisch genau die Programme
aufzählen die wir als
Koalitionsfraktionen auch für eine gute
Unterstützung für die ukrainischen
frauenkinder und Jugendlichen
identifiziert haben und die im übrigen
im Familienministerium seit Wochen und
mit ganz großem Engagement entsprechend
angepasst wurden angepasst werden und
mit eigenen Webauftritten mit
Übersetzungen und deswegen auch gerade
zielgerichtet an Ukrainerinnen gerichtet
sind Stichworte sind da früher Hilfen
sind sprachkitas stark in Beruf oder
auch das Programm Menschen stärken
Menschen das ist da bei diesen einzelnen
Programmen natürlich auch darum geht sie
Haushalt tierisch zu stärken das haben
wir auf dem Schirm und da freuen wir uns
auf die Zusammenarbeit im Rahmen der
Haushaltsberatungen und ich weiß
natürlich auch liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union dass sie an ihrem
gefühlten Alleinvertretungsanspruch als
Lautsprecher der Anliegen der Kommunen
hier in Deutschland festhalten diese
Zeiten die sind aber auch schon lange
vorbei und wenn sie da ganz ehrlich sind
und sich vermeintlich für die Kommunen
in die Bresche werfen wollen dann
geht das nicht ganz einher wir das was
ich höre das was wir hören aus den
Abstimmungen mit Bund mit Ländern vor
allen Dingen mit den Kommunen ist dass
diese ab die Abstimmung sehr sehr
konstruktiv laufen auf Ihren Wunsch zum
Beispiel wurde diese zentrale
Koordinierungsstelle für die Versorgung
von Heim und Waisen Kindern auf
Bundesebene eingerichtet wer allerdings
nicht konstruktiv ist das ist die CSU in
dieser Debatte und zwar schon seit
Wochen wenn unbegleitete minderjährige
Flüchtlinge wenn Minderjährige mit
Betreuern einreisen wir haben das gehört
auch in der Debatte Einzelplan 17 in der
vergangenen Woche dann sollten diese
Kinder auch entsprechend betreut werden
und möglichst schnell Zugang zu
Leistungen vom SGB 8 erhalten und nicht
unter das Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
fallen letzteres ist natürlich im Sinne
einer
restriktiveren Haus Ausführung aber dann
stellen Sie sich hier bitte nicht hin
und sagen Ihnen liegt das Wohl des
Kindes im Mittelpunkt dann stellen Sie
bitte diese Anträge nicht sondern dann
machen Sie bitte folgendes rufen Sie
Ihren MP an in Bayern und sagen Sie ihm
er soll sich bitte nicht länger quer
stellen auch im Rahmen der MPK nicht und
davon arbeiten dass nicht PMS
rausgegeben werden die eine Einigung die
er vorher zugestimmt hat im Nachhinein
ganz anders laufen
und jetzt gehe ich noch auf ihren Antrag
ein sie schreiben auf in ihrem Antrag
den Schutz für sie müssen wir jetzt in
den Vordergrund stellen und ihre
Integration ermöglichen ein gut
organisierter Start ist die Grundlage
dafür dass hilfesicherheit und
Integration für ukrainische frauenkinder
und Jugendliche gelingt und ich muss
Ihnen sagen es macht mich ein bisschen
traurig und zwar aus dem Grund weil es
so floskelhaft klingt weil sie mit dem
Schlagwort Integration der damit
verbundenen Herausforderung gar nicht
gerecht werden und zwar einerseits
nämlich zu ermöglichen dass diejenigen
die hier ankommen sofort einen Platz in
unserer Gesellschaft erhalten und sich
zumindest auch für eine Zeit hier ein
Leben aufbauen zu können und
gleichzeitig den starken Wunsch auch zu
respektieren ihre ukrainische Heimat
außerhalb der des ukrainischen
Territoriums hier weiter zu bewahren bis
sie nach Hause zurückkehren unsere
Bundesbildungsministerin kümmert sich
zum Beispiel im Bildungsbereich genau
darum dass das miteinander verzahnt ist
und dann werden wir noch ganz kurz frau
Präsidentin beim Stichwort Masterplan
ich verstehe natürlich ihren Wunsch ich
war auch hier in der letzten Legislatur
dabei dass Innenministerium hat sich da
ungern an Absprachen mit anderen Häusern
beteiligt aber auch diese Zeiten sind
vorbei deswegen brauchen wir flexible
schnelle Lösungen auf allen Ebenen aber
nicht einen staatlich zentralverordneten
Masterplan wir freuen uns dennoch auf
die Beratung im Ausschuss vielen Dank
Liebe Jensen für die FDP-Fraktion die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
und es ist ja auch noch vieles und der
nächste Redner der Beschluss
wenn wir weiter schauen auch was die
Integration für die Kinder in der Schule
in der Kita möglicherweise die Frauen
dann auf dem Arbeitsmarkt anbelangt
Krieg auf europäischem Boden und die
Bilder werden von Tag zu Tag
schrecklicher unerträglicher und
brutaler und deshalb zur Folge dass ein
Viertel des ukrainischen Volkes sich auf
der Flucht befindet vier Millionen
Menschen haben ihr Land verlassen und es
ist unsere Pflicht in Europa und in
Deutschland diesen europäischen
Binnenflüchtlingen Obhut und Schutz zu
gewähren und
fühlen mit den Menschen sie sind uns
nicht genug geographisch sondern auch
emotional nahe deswegen gibt es in
Deutschland eine große Hilfsbereitschaft
und deswegen möchte ich an dieser Stelle
allen danken die Menschen aufnehmen bei
sich zu Hause bei den ehrenamtlichen
aber auch bei den hauptamtlichen unseren
Behörden die damit betroffen sind mit
dieser Aufgabe ein herzliches Dankeschön
und jetzt
wäre Aufgabe dieser Bundesregierung
diese Hilfsbereitschaft aufzunehmen zu
fördern zu unterstützen damit es
weitergeht und Hilfe bestmöglich zu
organisieren durch diese Bundesregierung
hängt seit sechs Wochen der Entwicklung
hinterher
wir haben
keine durchgehende
Personenfeststellung wir haben kein
gleichmäßiges System der Registrierung
keine gut organisierte Verteilung der
Menschen innerhalb von Deutschland und
vor allem Frau Ministerin Spiegel wir
haben keinen ausreichenden Schutz von
Frauen und Kindern wenn Sie hier bei uns
in Deutschland ankommen
die Bundesregierung
[Musik]
weiß nämlich bis heute nicht wer wie
viel und wo die Menschen sich aufhalten
im übrigen ganz anders als Polen das
viel stärker belastet ist durch die
Flüchtlingszahlen und gleichzeitig
erklärt Frau Ministerin Veser die heute
im übrigen wieder mal mit Abwesenheit
glänzt wie oft in ihren vielen
Interviews etwa folgendes die Polizei
kontrolliert sehr intensiv in Bussen und
Zügen besonders die drittstadler ohne
ukrainischen Pass werden kontrolliert
und registriert die seit zwei Dinge zur
Folge erstens sie erkennt mit diesem
Aussagen an dass eine Kontrolle
notwendig ist sonst würde sie es nicht
immer wieder behaupten das zweite ist
aber diese Behauptung der Frau Feser
zuletzt in der Leipziger Volkszeitung am
vergangenen Samstag stimmt mit der
Wahrheit und der Realität nicht überein
es gibt keine vollständige
Personenfeststellung in Deutschland die
durchgeführt wird ins besondere nicht
bei drittstatern meine Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und deswegen wird die Innenministerin
ihre Aufgabe nicht zurecht zu wissen wer
und wie viel in Deutschland ist und das
ist ihre Verantwortung und sie schadet
damit nicht nur den
Sicherheitsinteressen unseres Landes
sondern in vielen Menschen Frauen und
Kindern die deshalb keinen Schutz
erfahren können Sie haben nichts gemacht
die beiden Ministerinnen weder Professor
noch Frau Spiegel wir haben im
Innenausschuss darauf hingewiesen
einzige Antwort wir werden die
Bundespolizei sensibilisieren bis heute
keine Schutzzone kein Schutzkonzept Frau
Ministerin Spiegel sie haben gerade
gesagt sie würden unaufgeregt Handeln
wegen mir können Sie auch aufgeregt
Handeln hauptsache sie handeln
und die Priesterin Veser ist auch auf
europäischer Ebene gescheitert ja die
meisten zustromsrichtlinie wurde
aktiviert das haben wir auch von Anfang
an begrüßt es ist ein gutes Mittel den
Menschen aus der Ukraine schnell und
unbürokratisch hier Aufnahme zu gewähren
aber es wurde entgegen den Vorschriften
in der Richtlinie selbst nicht beim
Beschluss festgestellt wie die
Aufnahmekapazitäten in den einzelnen
europäischen Ländern sind und jetzt ist
die Frau Ministerin Faeser nach Brüssel
gereist mit der Forderung einer
verbindlichen Quote letzte Woche sie ist
gescheitert sie ist ohne Ergebnis nach
Deutschland nach Berlin zurückgekommen
es gibt keine Solidarität in diesem
Bereich auf europäischer Ebene die
Ministerin ist gescheitert und sie möge
hier eine Lernkurve hinlegen für
zukünftige Verhandlungen auch in anderen
Bereichen der Migration damit sie so
nicht nochmals scheitert liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und das sieht offensichtlich das sieht
offensichtlich auch der
Koalitionspartner der Frau Ministerin so
insbesondere die Grünen ihr Vorsitzender
hat einen einen
Krisenstab im Bundeskanzleramt gefordert
ebenso die Vizepräsidentin Frau Göring
Eckart und bei der FDP nicht viel anders
der migrationsminister stammen aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen fordert ebenso
diesen Krisenstab im Kanzleramt und auch
außerhalb der Politik der
flüchtlingsbeauftragte der EKD fordert
ebenfalls ein Krisenstab nicht mehr beim
Innenministerium sondern Zusammenführung
Chefsache im Bundeskanzleramt ich hoffe
der Bundeskanzler hört diese Rufe aus
seiner Koalition und beispielsweise aus
der evangelischen Kirche herzlichen Dank
gesagt Alexander throm hier für die
CDU-Fraktion er ist der innenpolitische
Sprecher und hat hier auch den beiden
Ministerinnen an der Spiegel und auch
der bundesinnenministerin Faser
Versäumnisse vorgeworfen
hören wir mal was die
Sozialdemokraten dazu zu sagen die
Abgeordnete
königstan Yüksel mit jedem
Innenausschuss
Kollege Tromm zu ihnen vielleicht am
Anfang ich glaube ihnen müsste bekannt
sein dass die Ministerin heute
entschuldigt ist und deswegen finde ich
das einfach unwürdig dass sie das immer
wieder in jeder Debatte versuchen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Nachrichten
und Bilder aus der Ukraine zerreißen
einem das Herz noch vor ein paar Wochen
gingen die Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
ihrem normalen Alltag nach so wie wir
hier Kinder gingen zur Schule und
verabredeten sich zum Spielen Menschen
gingen morgens zur Arbeit unternahmen
abends etwas mit ihrer Familie und
machten Pläne fürs Wochenende doch
plötzlich ist alles vorbei
Putins Angriffskrieg hat die Menschen in
der Ukraine aus ihrem Leben gerissen
putinsbomben legen Wohnhäuser und
Krankenhäuser in Schutt und Asche
Menschen müssen ansehen wie ihre Lieben
sterben dieses unermessliche Leid ist
nicht in Worte zu fassen
liebe Kollegen Kollegen Menschen die zu
uns fliehen bieten wir zuallererst
Schutz das ist unsere humanitäre Pflicht
diesen Schutz geben wir Ihnen gemeinsam
mit unseren europäischen Partnern
gemeinsam mit Bund Ländern und Kommunen
gemeinsam mit vielen Ehrenamtlichen
hauptamtlichen Helferinnen und Helfern
und auch wenn es heute schon mehrmals
gesagt wurde man kann es nicht oft genug
sagen Danke an alle engagierten
Helferinnen Helfer
solche humanitären Katastrophen können
wir nur gemeinsam bewältigen deshalb ist
es wichtig dass wir zusammenarbeiten und
solidarisch zusammenstehen die
rascheaktivierung des massenzustroms
Richtlinie zeigt dass die Idee eines
solidarischen Europas mehr denn je mit
Leben gefüllt ist die Richtlinie
ermöglicht den Schutzsuchenden
europaweit eine schnelle und
unüberokratische Aufnahme sowie
sowie schnellen Zugang zu verschiedenen
Bereichen des Lebens zu Bildung zu zum
Arbeitsmarkt aber auch zu
Sozialleistungen und zu medizinischen
Grundversorgung hierunter fällt auch ein
psychische Behandlung die besonders
wichtig ist denn Krieg und Bomben
traumatisieren das Abschiednehmen von
Söhnen Vätern Brüdern ehmennern nicht
wissen ob man sie wieder sieht
traumatisiert
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt
viele Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine die
erstmal bei Verwandten und Freunden
unterkommen ich finde es richtig dein
Flüchtenden und teilweise
traumatisierten Menschen diese
Möglichkeit zu geben denn nach geltendem
Recht können sie sich 90 Tage visumsfrei
in Europa aufhalten bleiben sie länger
bei uns oder brauchen sie staatliche
Unterstützung werden sie ohnehin
registriert also ich verstehe diese
Debatte die sie hier führen überhaupt
nicht liebe Kollegen Kollegen der Union
an ihre Richtung nachdem ich miterlebt
habe wie sie in den letzten zwei
Legislaturperioden in der
Integrationspolitik agiert haben was
alles blockiert wurde und nicht ging
Stichwort Integrationskurse für alle von
Anfang an dann freue ich mich zwar dass
die Rolle in der Opposition wohl jetzt
etwas so ein sich beigetragen hat
wundere mich aber umso mehr über den
vorliegenden Antrag den Sie hier
vorgelegt haben
wenn die Union von einem Masterplan
spricht denke ich zuerst an Horst
Seehofer
dessen Masterplan war nun wirklich alles
andere als gute Migration und
Integrationspolitik
da ging es da ging es vor allem um
Verschärfungen Asylrecht es ging nicht
um das wichtigste den Schutz der
geflüchteten Menschen ich bin froh ich
bin froh dass wir mit Nancy fesern und
eine Innenministerin haben die die
Herausforderung tatkräftig angeht so
gibt es ein neu eingerichtetes zentrales
Hilfeportal German das gebündelt auf
ukrainisch und russisch über Aufenthalt
Hilfsangebote Unterkünfte und ärztliche
Versorgung informiert sobald die
geflüchteten im Netz der Telekom
ankommen werden sie mit einer SMS auf
das Hilfeportal hingewiesen in den
ankunftsbahnhöfen und Unterkünften sind
die helfende für mögliche
gefahrensensibilisiert
Flyer und Anzeigetafel waren zusätzlich
und klären über dubiose Hilfsangebote
auf die Bundespolizei ist verstärkt
präsent-
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wichtig
ist aber auch dass die Menschen
schneller Struktur und Alltag bekommen
durch Zugang zum Bildungssystem und zum
Arbeitsmarkt aber auch durch Angebote
die ein gutes ankommen ermöglichen
deshalb stehen den geflüchteten
vielfältige Angebote zur Verfügung so
hilft zum Beispiel die individuelle
Migrationsberatung bei Fragen direkt
nach der aus Ankunft es gibt
erstorientierungskurse zum Einleben in
Deutschland
integrations- und Sprachkurse sowie
Kurse speziell für Frauen
kostenlose Online-Angebote zum Deutsch
lernen aber auch zusätzliche
berufssprachkurse um den Zugang zum
Arbeitsmarkt zu erleichtern
Angesicht der vielen Frauen und Kinder
die zu uns kommen ist auch eine
Kinderbetreuung sehr wichtig lassen Sie
mich auch dazu zwei Beispiele nennen das
gerade gestartete Bundesprogramm
Integrationskurs mit Kind unterstützt
sie kurzsteilnehmerin bei der Betreuung
nicht schulpflichtiger Kinder oder das
Bundesprogramm stark im Beruf welches
Frauen mit Kindern bei der Orientierung
in Deutschland und bei der Integration
in unseren Arbeitsmarkt hilft
liebe Kollegen Kollegen sie sehen wir
haben bereits viele gute neue und alte
Unterstützung und Hilfsangebote für
geflüchtete geschaffen unter Leitung des
Bundesinnenministeriums Stimmen Bund und
Länder sich außerdem wöchentlich in der
extra geschaffen Bund Länder
Koordinierungsstelle Ukraine ab heute
findet auch den
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz statt in
der es unter anderem um die Klärung der
offenen Finanzierungsfragen geht ich
wünsche mir dass diese nicht ewig dauert
und diskutiert wird sondern dass wir
gemeinsam alle an einem Strang ziehen
und während die Union an vermeintlichen
masterplänen tüftelt arbeiten wir weiter
konsequent an pragmatischen und guten
Lösungen denn wir fliehenden
denn die fliehenden Menschen brauchen
vor allem eins auch das müsste ihnen
endlich mal bekannt sein sie brauchen
schnell und unbürokratisch Schutz und
Hilfe herzlichen Dank
jedes Teil Yüksel war das für die
SPD-Fraktion sie sitzt im Ausschuss für
Inneres und
Heimat
es sind ja ganz verschiedene Ressorts
auch betroffen wenn wir hier über
Debatte darüber reden beziehungsweise
der Bundestag sich mit diesem Antrag der
Unionsfraktion beschäftigt wie ein
Masterplan für Hilfe Sicherheit
Integration für ukrainische Frauen
Kinder und Jugendliche aussehen könnte
auch eine bildungspolitische
Querschnittsaufgabe natürlich Nicole
höchst jetzt dazu für die AFD denn er
zeigt dass sie von der Union die erste
Stufe der bitteren Erkenntnis erklommen
haben die da lautet ihre
Zuwanderungspolitik auf dem
flüchtlingsticket dazu Kontrollverlust
in verschiedenen Bereichen geführt sie
stellen vollkommen zutreffend fest
Sicherheit und Schutz geht nur wenn wir
wissen wer zu uns gekommen und bei wem
sie oder er untergekommen ist damit sind
Sie schon mal einen Schritt weiter als
die jetzige Bundesregierung die ihren
Merkel hoch nun sind sie halt da Kurs
seit 2015 fortsetzt
vielen Dank Union für gutes Beispiel von
partiella Amnesie dass uns heute als
Antrag vorliegt ich freue mich dass Sie
nun die Sicherheit für Frauen Kinder und
Jugendliche für Sie entdeckt haben für
sich entdeckt haben zwar später aber
immerhin aber warum die Einschränkung
auf ukrainische Flüchtlinge
Kontrolle und Niveauverlust wurde
Deutschland jüngst auch für die Bildung
mit Blick von außen bescheinigt dies
nahmen Bildungspolitiker der AFD aus
Bund und Ländern am vergangenen Montag
auch in den Blick bei ihrer Resolution
zur Beschulung von ukrainischen
Flüchtlingskindern diese sollen in
Deutschland bestmöglich auf die Rückkehr
in ihr Heimatland vorbereitet und
Forderungen aus der Ukraine hierbei
beachtet werden wir erkennen das Recht
ukrainischer Schüler auf schulische
Bildung an selbstverständlich muss für
Sie schulische Bildung in Deutschland
gesichert werden auch zu einem Zeitpunkt
in dem die Schulen durch Lehrermangel
und durch corona-maßnahmen Politik der
langjährigen
bildungsnotstandsleugner in Bund und
Ländern ohnehin am Rande der
Belastungsgrenze stehen ein Konzept zur
Beschulung von ukrainischen
Flüchtlingskindern muss die Bedürfnisse
der Schüler und die bildungspolitischen
Forderungen aus der Ukraine zur
Grundlage nehmen die die ukrainische
Generalkonsulin Irina tiwinka während
der Kultusministerkonferenz im März
geäußert hat die Ukraine ist eine stolze
Nation die um ihre Unabhängigkeit kämpft
und ihre Eigenständigkeit bewahren
möchte anders als die märz 2015 handelt
es sich im Jahr 2020 22 überwiegend um
Kriegsflüchtlinge die nicht in
Deutschland bleiben sondern in ihrer
Heimat zurückkehren werden
leider hat no borders no nation
Deutschland aus 2015 und Corona nichts
gelernt und hat es somit gedacht Schutz
und bildungsversprechen zu halten
solange die Weichen nicht wie zum
Beispiel nach dem Vorbild Polens ganz
grundsätzlich neu gestellt werden
Doppelpunkt Grenzzaun Grenzsicherung
schnelle Verfahren rigorosa Abschiebung
nicht bleibeberechtigter die Aufnahme
ukrainischer Flüchtlinge zeigt uns in
Deutschland Dinge die sie alle meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren die
letzten Jahre
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das Wort Julian Pahlke
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte DemokratInnen und Demokraten
vielleicht erstmal ein paar Worte hier
an den ganz weit rechten Rand ich bin
sehr froh dass ich der Verfassungsschutz
um sie kümmert sie sind ein
Sicherheitsrisiko für dieses Land
wir leben in wahrlich ungewöhnlichen
Zeiten die Union schwingt sich zum
Retter geflüchteter Menschen auf ich bin
fast ein bisschen erschrocken das hätte
ihnen nach 16 Jahren an
syrrechtsverschärfung und Obergrenzen
hätte ich Ihnen das gar nicht zugetraut
schaut man aber auch nur ein bisschen
genauer hin dann wird klar für die Union
gibt es offenbar zwei Arten von
geflüchteten Menschen einmal ukrainische
Frauen und Kinder die jetzt von dem
russischen Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
fliehen und dann alle anderen stimmt
unter den geflüchteten aus der Ukraine
sind viele Frauen und Kinder für die die
Bundesregierung und unsere Ministerin
Anne Spiegel eben wie sie auch schon
berichtet hat eine ganze Reihe an
Maßnahmen beschlossen hat
aber es fliehen eben nicht
ausschließlich Frauen und Kinder auch
wenn die Union das gerne so hätte
plötzlich wollen sie SIM-Karten und man
geflüchtete verteilen ist ja eine nette
Idee aber warum denn nur an Frauen und
warum nur an ukrainische
Staatsangehörige in guter alter
unionsmann hier lassen sie etliche
Menschen außen vor sie ignorieren
Menschen die keinen ukrainischen Pass
haben die männlich oder wir sind alte
Menschen Menschen mit Behinderung
Menschen die in der Ukraine gearbeitet
oder studiert haben Flucht hat viele
Gesichter Flucht ist nicht nur weiß und
weiblich
ich hatte gehofft dass die grauen Herren
bei der CDU in CSU ihr neu entdecktes
Mitgefühl auch für etwas Sinnvolles
nutzen aber auch jetzt reden sie nur von
Kontrollen und Registrierung und dabei
sind die juristisch überhaupt noch nicht
mal möglich ihre Agenda war doch in den
letzten Jahren eine ganz andere
abschiebezentren Arbeitsverbote hau
abgesetzt und ihre absurde Obergrenze
ich würde ja gerne glauben dass sie
jetzt ein ehrliches Interesse am Schutz
von Menschen auf der Flucht entwickelt
haben ihre Politik überall dort wo sie
an der Macht sind spricht aber eine
andere Sprache für die wenigsten
Probleme sind ihre pauschalen
Forderungen nach sogenannten
Grenzkontrollen eine Lösung die
Identität geflüchtet haben wird bereits
bei jedem Grenzübertritt in Polen in
Ungarn oder Rumänien festgestellt danach
ist die Bundespolizei an den Grenzen der
Bundesrepublik präsent kontrolliert die
Züge kontrolliert in den Zügen die Pässe
das habe ich selbst gesehen als ich aus
Warschau nach Berlin gefahren bin
wir brauchen keine zusätzliche
Registrierung und aufwendige
Grenzkontrollen die die Flucht weiter
verzögern und nur ihre Seehofer noch
Sergi bedienen
wir leben in ungewöhnlichen Zeiten es
sind Zeiten in denen wir zeigen können
zu was wir in der Lage sind so wie die
10.000 freiwilligen sie helfen an den
Bahnhöfen bei Behördengängen verschaffen
Wohnungen und helfen überall da wo es
nötig ist nicht erst seit dem 24 Februar
sondern seit 2015 reden sie von der
Union und jetzt bitte nicht davon
christlich zu handeln wenn sie
gleichzeitig Menschen im Mittelmeer
ertrinken lassen herzlichen Dank
Julian Pahlke war das für die Grünen er
sitzt im Bundestags Innenausschuss
[Applaus]
und der nächste Redner an der Debatte
Stefan Thomy fdp-
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin für ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Kollegin Doro Bär Liebe Alexander
throm bei ihren Debatten Beiträgen habe
ich mich erinnert an das Schauspiel der
zerbrochene Krug von Heinrich von Kleist
da geht es um den Dorfrichter Adam der
über eine Tat zu Gericht sitzen muss von
der genau weiß dass er selber sie
begangen hat und ein bisschen das kam
mir an den in den Sinn
als als als die aufgezählt haben welche
Fehler und Versäumnisse diese Regierung
sich zu Schulden kommen ließen es sind
eigentlich die Fehler und Versäumnisse
ihrer Regierung aus letzten Flüchtling
ein nationalen flüchtlingsgipfel
entzünde ich mich sehr gut hielt die
Union in den 2015 folgende für für
völlig unnötig oder anderes Thema ein
gleichmäßig eine gleichmäßig europäische
Verteilung der Flüchtlingen ist auch der
Union in der letzten Krise nicht
gelungen von daher sind die gleichen
Versäumnisse und Fehler die damals schon
geschehen sind die sie jetzt uns
verhalten und auf der anderen Seite
bedarfsorientierte Unterstützung
psychoziale Betreuung gab es das dann in
den Jahren 2015 folgende nein all das
gab es nicht das sind ihre Versäumnisse
und Fehler gewesen die es uns vorwerfen
und die Frau Spiegel wahrscheinlich
besser weiß hat als ihn damals gelungen
ist
und dann gibt es eine ganze Reihe von
Punkten die machen wir doch eigentlich
ja sie sie fordern jetzt ein eine die
beförderungsabläufe zu verbessern
Bundesminister Volker Wissing hat im
Verkehrsministerium ein
koordinationsstab eingerichtete genau
das tut und leistet was sie was sie
eigentlich voriges kann man sagen es
läuft ja nicht alles perfekt noch nicht
alles Rund ja weil die Dinge sich auch
laufend ändern aber es ist im Ganges es
läuft wie ich finde eigentlich schon
sehr gut
oder Schulangebote für Kinder wurden
spricht denn Bildungsministerin stark
Watzinger jeden Tag und ich finde dass
die Kommunen die Beschulung natürliche
Kinder in den Schulen eigentlich sehr
gut meistern aber das heißt nicht dass
ich dass ich es alles falsch finde was
in ihrem Antrag drin steht Thema
Registrierung ja natürlich wäre es gut
um bedarfsgerechte Angebote für die
frauenkinder zu unterbreiten dass wir
ein genaues Bild haben wie viele
Menschen sind denn da und wer ist da nur
es ist eben das haben ja gerade eben in
der konverse gehört rechtlich und auch
faktisch nicht ganz so einfach denn wenn
ein ukrainische Staatsangehörige mit
biometrischen Pass in den Schengenraum
einreist und vielleicht im Privat-PKW
von von Freunden Bekannten Verwandten
über Polen Slowakei Ungarn Österreich
nach Deutschland kommt oder Tschechien
und sich dann hier innerhalb von von 90
Tagen keine Leist keine Leistungen
beantragt und vielleicht auch wieder
weiterreist oder ausreißt ja dann ist es
rechtlich und faktisch gar nicht so ein
Kollegen da ist jemand da erlauben sie
noch eine Zwischenfrage des Kollegen
Trogen gerne
ich danke Ihnen Herr Kollege tue ich
danke zunächst einmal auch dass sie
eingangs ihre Rede bestätigt haben dass
in dieser Bundesregierung entsprechende
Fehler und Versäumnisse passieren sie
haben die zwar dann bezogen auf das Jahr
2015/2016 aber schade ist dass diese
Versäumnisse in ihrer Bundesregierung
ist 2022 zumindest wiederholt werden
nach ihrer eigenen Aussage das zweite
was ich fragen will sie haben darauf
hingewiesen dass zu Recht Ukrainer mit
biometrischen Pässen hier nach
Deutschland kommen dürfen und
Freizügigkeit genießen frage sie aber
wie sie den feststellen dass die
ukrainischen Staatsbürger tatsächlich
biometrische Pässe besitzen müssen die
sie dazu nicht eine Personenfeststellung
durchführen Frage 1 und Frage 2 sie
waren glaube ich gestern dabei im
Innenausschuss als der Präsident der
Bundespolizei bestätigt hat das genau
diese Personenfeststellung auch in den
Zügen und Bussen nicht vollständig
stattfindet können Sie das bestätigen
also Kollege der Triumph 6 und habe ich
nicht von unseren Fehlern sondern ich
habe vorher dass sie uns Fehler
vorhalten die aber ihre eigenen Fehler
gewesen sind das macht ein Unterschied
und zum zweiten
erfordert natürlich die Grenzkontrolle
einen Schengen und EU-Außengrenzen Polen
Ungarn Slowakei sind Schengen Staaten
Rumänien ist kein Englisch hat aber ein
eine u-staat dort an diesen Außengrenzen
findet die die Zutrittskontrolle statt
wenn aber sich jemand
erlaubtermaßen in den diesen Raum
begeben hat auch dank der Notfall
Richtlinien und der Beschlüsse der
EU-Kommission dann kann er natürlich
auch innerhalb der Europäischen Union
weitreichend andere Unionsländer und das
geschieht natürlich und das erfahren Sie
auch nicht automatisch aber ich habe
gesagt es wäre schon wichtig ein
genaueres Bild zu erhalten wer ist denn
nun eigentlich bei uns und dadurch muss
man sich Unterhaltung sagt ich ja auch
das sind durchaus Dinge drin die ich
nicht total falsch finde es wäre eine
Tat wichtig zu wissen wer ist denn bei
uns unbedarfsgerecht die Menschen hier
ankommen auch zu versorgen vielleicht
auch längerfristig zu versorgen von der
ist das schon ein wichtiges Bild das
aber etwas anderes als
Registrierungspflicht denn da frage ich
mich wie wollen Sie das denn faktisch
das ist der Unterschied zu dem was was
Sie gesagt haben ja aber ich sagte eben
nicht allezeitig für völlig verkehrt und
auch das Thema Gesundheitscheck
verwaltungslotsen ihrem Antrag finde ich
Ideen über die man sich durchaus
unterhalten kann von daher bin ich der
Meinung es wäre jetzt auch schade ihren
Antrag in sofortabstimmung abzulehnen
aus den Gründen die ich soeben gesagt
habe lasst uns doch diesen Antrag von
Ihnen in aller Ruhe konzentriert im
Ausschuss beraten von daher wäre ich für
eine Verweisung in den Innenausschuss
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
hier für die FDP-Fraktion
ob nachher über diesen Antrag abgestimmt
wird oder das ganze überwiesen wird
und das ist nämlich noch nicht ganz klar
weiter noch auf die Argumente der
Unionsfraktion die ja hier diesen Antrag
vorgelegt hat Josef Oster spricht
verehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Menschen in Not Kriegsflüchtlingen zu
helfen das ist eine gemeinsame
Überzeugung die unser Land und unsere
Gesellschaft verbindet und auszeichnet
und das ist auch etwas was uns hier ja
fraktionsübergreifend verbindet wenn man
mal von der AFD absieht und wenn ich das
als Annahme hier voraussetze dann
verwundern einige Wortbeiträge hier aus
der Regierungskoalition doch sehr denn
das im Moment bei der Aufnahme der
Kriegsflüchtlinge alles gut läuft die
Dinge in Ordnung sind das kann doch
nicht im Ernst ihre Einschätzung der
Lage sein meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
und Frau Ministerin Spiegel hier schöne
zu Reden zu halten das reicht in einer
solchen Situation nicht jetzt ist
Tatkraft gefragt nicht reden sondern
handeln und das geschieht seitens der
Bundesregierung viel zu wenig und dass
sie nach sechs Wochen zu der Erkenntnis
kommen sich mal die Situation in Polen
anzuschauen das begrüße ich ausdrücklich
auch wenn es lange sechs Wochen gedauert
hat aber die Polen machen vieles besser
und das werden sie dann schnell erkennen
Frau Ministerin
aber ich will ihnen eines zu guten
erhalten sie sind heute zumindest hier
das spricht für sie und ich wundere mich
dass die Innenministerin das darf ich
hier sagen bei einer so zentralen
Debatte heute nicht hier anwesend ist
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich
will aber auch
aufgreifen was Herr Thome gesagt hat
also es gehört ja schon viel Kreativität
dazu die Folgen die wir jetzt Erleben
des ukrainekrieges und das was wir im
Zusammenhang mit der Aufnahme von
kriegsflüchtigen erleben auch noch der
alten Regierungen die Schuhe zu schieben
also der Krieg begann ja nun definitiv
Nachkriegs
nach dem Kriegsbeginn und von daher kann
ich darf nicht verstehen dass sie auch
diese Klamotte heute hier noch
ausgepackt habe da war ihre Kollegin
Yüksel von der SPD ehrlicher sie hat
einige Förderprogramme die funktionieren
hier aufgezeigt hat aber nicht erwähnt
dass die ganzen Förderprogramme von der
alten Regierung aufgelegt wurden meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
also ich glaube es gibt viel
Handlungsbedarf und ich will zwei drei
Punkte hier noch mal aufgreifen das
zentrale ist und das haben wir hier
mehrere auch erwähnt das zentrale
Instrument ist eine lückenlose
Registrierung ohne eine konsequente
Registrierung können wir keine
Sicherheit gewährleisten ohne eine
lückenlose Registrierung kann es keine
optimale Unterstützung der Flüchtlinge
geben und ohne eine lückenlose
Registrierung kann es auch keine
Integration der Menschen geben das ist
Grundvoraussetzung für alles meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
der nächste Punkt ist eine gerechte
Verteilung es ist zweifellos keine
einfache Aufgabe ein gerechtes System
innerhalb Deutschlands zu organisieren
und ein gerechtes System innerhalb
Europas zu organisieren diese Aufgabe
ist schwierig das räumlich ein mir fehlt
aber seitens der Bundesregierung ein
ernsthaftes Bemühen überhaupt nur eine
Lösung finden zu wollen und genau das
geschieht zu wenig meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
es gäbe eine Menge zu sagen ich will zum
Schluss noch einmal festhalten die
Bundesregierung macht es sich in dieser
vielleicht größten Krise seit der seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg für meine Begriffe
viel zu einfach wir haben eine wirklich
wunderbare Situation was die Akzeptanz
und die Hilfsbereitschaft in unserer
Gesellschaft anbetrifft aber wir dürfen
nicht verkennen dass diese Akzeptanz und
Hilfsbereitschaft nicht unbegrenzt ist
und die Menschen in unserem Land haben
die berechtigte Erwartung dass die
Bundesregierung die Flüchtlingsbewegung
im Griff hat und diese Erwartung erfüllt
die Bundesregierung bis zur Stunde nicht
und deshalb empfehle ich nochmals
und das empfehle ich nochmals schauen
Sie sich unseren Antrag noch mal genau
an er ist eine verdammt gute
Handlungsgrundlage
sagt Josef Oster für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion
13 Punkte und Schritte sind dort
aufgelistet in diesem Antrag für die
heutige Sitzung auch offiziell
entschuldigt ist heute
sportministerkonferenz und die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und dann
nimmt sie daran teil ich bitte das
das Kanzleramt hat sich gerade bei mir
entschuldigt kommt gleich wieder müsst
muss in den Haushaltsausschuss wird
gleich wieder ersetzt werden nein die
Staatsministerin wird gleich kommen der
Wechsel war gerade angekündigt das
soweit zur Information und jetzt gebe
ich das Wort an den nächsten Rede und
sagt die
Bundestagspräsidentin hier Yvonne mag
was weil jetzt schon mehrfach der
Vorwurf kam das nennt sie Phaser die
bundesinnenministerin nicht anwesend ist
also hier nochmals die Klarstellung
ich bitte jetzt um Ruhe weil der Redner
dem Redner ist schon das Wort erteilt
und ich bitte die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn Sie hier eine Debatte
führen wollen entweder mit
kurzinterventionen oder Zwischenfragen
zu agieren Herr malottky sie haben das
Wort
ich bitte jetzt dass der Redner die
Möglichkeit hat seine Rede zu halten
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
es macht wütend dass wir über den Schutz
der geflüchteten Menschen aus der
Ukraine überhaupt diskutieren müssen es
macht wütend dass Millionen Kinder und
Frauen fliehen weil das russische Regime
ein brutalen Angriffskrieg führt
deswegen muss noch mal klar gesagt
werden der beste Schutz für ukrainische
Kinder und Frauen ist das sofortige Ende
dieses sinnlose und grausamen Krieges
und der schnelle Wiederaufbau der
Ukraine
solange dieser Krieg nicht beendet ist
müssen wir alles dafür tun die
ukrainischen Familien und Kinder bei uns
behütet aufzunehmen wir müssen ihnen
Schutz bieten wir müssen ihnen die
Möglichkeit geben hier in Deutschland
anzukommen und eine neue Perspektive zu
finden
ich habe mich deshalb gefreut dass die
Kollegin brehe und Prien am 1 April ein
Masterplan zu Integration ukrainische
Kinder und Jugendliche vorgelegt haben
dieser Masterplan ist gut oder besser
gesagt gut zusammengetragen weil sie
viele Forderungen Vorhaben aus unserem
Koalitionsvertrag aus unseren reden zum
Haushalt des Familienministeriums und
aus dem Familienausschuss in ihrem
Masterplan zusammengefasst haben ich
nenne hier nur exemplarisch die
verstärkten Bemühungen für die
Ausbildung von Fachkräften und die
Aufstockung von bestehenden
kita-programmen
ich habe mich auch gefreut weil damit
eine gemeinsame Position aller
demokratischen Fraktionen in der Sache
möglich gewesen wäre
umso enttäuschter war ich als ich am
Dienstagabend ihren Antrag erhalten
haben
es ist nichts mehr von konkreten
Maßnahmen zu Integration der
ukrainischen Kinder in unsere Kitas und
Schuhe zu lesen dabei ist genau das
dringend notwendig
Kollegin beer was denn in ihrer Fraktion
passiert das am Ende der gut
zusammengeschriebene Masterplan zu so
einer Enttäuschung geworden ist warum
erwähnen sie nicht mehr die notwendigen
Ausbau des Programms sprachkiters wo ist
ihre Unterstützung für einen Fortführung
des gute kita-gesetzes sind verschwunden
warum wollen sie auf einmal keine
bundesfinanzierte fachkräfteoffensive
mehr für die Kitas obwohl genau jetzt
jede zusätzliche Erzieherin Erzieher
dringend benötigt wird
sie fordern sie fordern sie fordern
stattdessen sie fordert stattdessen
völlig unkonkret und der Nummer 9 Zitat
die Länder und Kommunen bei der
Integration der ukrainischen Kinder und
Jugendlichen in das Bildungs- und
Betreuungssystem System pragmatisch und
schnell zu unterstützen das ist eine
Floskel und seit der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von vor
drei Wochen bereits vereinbart zwischen
Bund und Ländern das alles ist schon
enttäuschend genug
aber an anderer Stelle handeln Sie
konkret gegen gute und schnelle Hilfe
für gefürchtete Kinder ihre
Landesregierung aus Bayern und
Schleswig-Holstein Erinnerung Frau Prien
hat den Maßnahmen Masterplan geschrieben
wollen auf der Integrationsministerin
Konferenz nicht für das dringend
benötigte bundesweite Programm zur
Ausweitung von griffbereit Stimmen dabei
ist griffbereit genau das richtige
Mittel denn es bietet den ersten Schritt
um ukrainische Kinder und Eltern hier
vor Ort in die frühkindliche Bildung
einzubinden das hat mich enttäuscht aber
was mich wirklich wütend macht ist ein
bitterer Halbsatz in ihrem Antrag denn
dort heißt es für alle Maßnahmen die sie
jetzt vorschlagen Zitat der Deutsche
Bundestag fordert die Bundesregierung
auf im Rahmen der zur Verfügung
stehenden Haushaltsmittel endlich einen
Masterplan zu entstehen Zitat Ende alle
ihre Ideen für die schnelle und
notwendige Hilfe stellen Sie also unter
einen Finanzierungsvorbehalt
für sie muss die Integration der
ukrainischen Familien und Kinder ein
haushaltspolitisches nullsumspiel sein
da stellt sich mir die Frage wie ernst
Sie Ihre Vorstellung Vorschläge
tatsächlich meinen ich bin froh ich bin
froh dass wir als Ampelkoalition einen
anderen Weg gehen und mit Hochdruck an
einem ergänzungshaushalt arbeiten wir
werden so schnell und unkompliziert
Hilfe ermöglichen ohne versteckten
finanzierungsarbeit das sorgt für
dringend benötiges zusätzliches Geld für
die Arbeit in Kitas und Schulen und wir
werden diese Mittel brauchen
denn ErzieherInnen und LehrerInnen sagen
mir wir wollen die Kinder fördern aber
es muss wir müssen behutsam vorgehen und
Sie müssen die richtigen
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen sie sagen mir
wir brauchen niedrigschwelle
anschwellige Angebote für die Kinder von
denen viele traumatisiert sind sie sagen
mir wir brauchen zusätzliches Personal
sie sagen die wir brauchen zusätzliche
Unterstützung für Ehrenamtliche die
Familien mit außerschulischen
Aktivitäten helfen
sie sagen mir wir brauchen zusätzliche
Mittel für die psychologische Betreuung
der Kinder und Frauen die auf ihre
Flucht teilweise Schreckliches erlebt
haben das alles wäre mit einem
Finanzierungsvorbehalt wie sie Ihnen
hier vorschlagen nicht möglich Ihr
Antrag bewirkt genau deswegen genau das
Gegenteil von dem was er verspricht
jeder der wirklich helfen will muss
ihren Antrag ablehnen danke
sagt Erik von malowski für die
SPD-Fraktion ja und was da noch ein
Haushalt
sbelastungen
gebraucht werden wird das ist ja
deswegen auch offen gelassen worden in
den
etat-beratungen derzeit befindet sich ja
der Haushalt für 2022 in den
parlamentarischen Beratungen und der
Bundesfinanzminister hatte ein
ergänzungshaushalt angekündigt unter
anderem um die Hilfe für die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge da noch mit
einzubeziehen
dieser Satz einer jungen ukrainischen
Studentin hat mich ganz besonders
berührt wir hören so viel über die
Flüchtlinge die zu uns kommen führen
Gespräche treffen Sie vor Ort und das
sind so viele Frauen junge Mädchen
Kinder dabei die Hoffnungen haben dass
sie hier gut aufgenommen werden dass sie
ihre Zukunft hier fortsetzen können dass
sie gut integriert werden dass sie die
Chance auf Bildung haben und dass sie
das was sie sich in der Ukraine
aufgebaut haben jetzt nicht auch noch
verlieren wie so vieles was sie eben
zurücklassen mussten und deshalb ist es
unsere gemeinsame Verantwortung dass wir
Ihnen diese Zukunft ermöglichen und das
was ich heute teilweise an Vorwürfen
gerade von den letzten Rednern gehört
habe das macht mich wirklich sprachlos
ich frage mich was tut die
Bundesregierung dafür dass diese junge
Menschen eine Zukunft haben wir haben
was ich bisher wahrnehme ist nach wie
vor eine unklare Datenlage wie viele
Kinder und Jugendliche überhaupt hier
sind und auch eine Konzept und teilweise
sogar Sprachlosigkeit der
Bundesregierung wir haben eine
Bundesfamilienministerin die gerade
schon den Saal verlassen hat die mehr
mit ihrer Vergangenheit beschäftigt ist
als mit den aktuellen Themen und alle
Punkte alle Punkte die heute beantworten
sind sind Programme und Initiativen aus
der letzten oder aus den letzten
Regierungen die jetzt fortgeführt werden
was richtig ist aber alles was jetzt
genannt wurde sind die Aktivitäten von
Ehrenamtlern von der Stiftung für
Ehrenamt und Engagement von
Hilfsorganisationen und wir bedanken uns
zurecht bei ihnen aber das reicht nicht
wir brauchen auch eigenes Engagement
dieser Bundesfamilienministerin und das
gleich das gilt für die bundesbildungs-
und Forschungsministerin wir haben stand
letzte Woche 41.000 Kinder und
Jugendliche in den deutschen Schulen und
viele auch in den Kindergärten und es
werden hunderttausende kommen und vor
Ort ist die Frage wie bewältigen wir das
denn die Schulen sind seit zwei Jahren
wegen Corona im Ausnahmezustand die
Kindergärten sind gut gefüllt das ist
eine riesen Kraftanstrengung dann gucke
ich in mein eigenes Land wo die SPD
Bildungsministerin sagt die integrieren
wir alle in den Regelunterricht die
stecken wir einfach in die Klassen dazu
ob das eine Lösung ist für die Kinder
die jetzt traumatisiert her ankommen und
für die Kinder die schon in den Schulen
sind da will ich mein großes
Fragezeichen dahinter machen
und wenn sie dann unsere
Bundesbildungsministerin zum großen Ziel
gemacht hat
Bildungsgerechtigkeit in diesem Land zu
fördern dann kann sie genau an dieser
Stelle zum ersten mal anfangen
Bildungsgerechtigkeit für die Kinder Sie
zu uns kommen und Bildungsgerechtigkeit
für die sie schon da sind da warte ich
konkrete Hilfe konkrete Unterstützung
und nicht einfach ein Abarbeiten des
bisherigen Koalitionsvertrags
und das gilt übrigens auch für den
Bundesgesundheitsminister es gibt auch
eine Menge Gesundheitsfragen die zu
klären sind da werden die Impfzentren
jetzt geschlossen wir alle wissen wir
haben eine Maß an impfpflichten unserem
Land für die Kinder in den Kindergärten
und den Schulen es sind Untersuchungen
zu machen wir schließen die Impfzentren
die so eine wertvolle Unterstützung sein
könnten auch in dieser Situation die ja
in den nächsten Wochen noch schlimmer
werden wird
und ich habe mich gefragt Frau Bünger
von den Linken warum beschimpfen sie
eigentlich hier die Union
und es ist mir sehr schnell klar
geworden weil die Situation in Ländern
wie Berlin wo sie mitregieren besonders
prekär ist und da stehen die ehrenamte
am Bahnhof und sagen diese Regierung
lässt uns alleine wir können nicht altes
alles Schultern als Ehrenamtler wir
brauchen mehr Unterstützung gerade von
dieser Regierung hier in Berlin und
deshalb sagen wir es braucht einen
Masterplan es braucht einen Masterplan
für die Integration der Kinder- und
Jugendlichen wir unterstützen gerne auch
mit konkreten Maßnahmen wir sind bereit
mitzumachen es muss eine gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengung kommen ich erwarte da
auch mehr Engagement dieser
Bundesregierung
mehr Engagement fordert von der
Bundesregierung Nadine schön für die
cdu/csu-fraktion hat sie gesprochen und
sie sehen es verehrte Zuschauer ein
kleiner Hinweis wir haben natürlich
abgesehen hier von den Bundestags
Beratungen auch immer noch einen Blick
was ist sonst an aktuellen Geschehnissen
gibt wir erwarten unter anderem zum
Abschluss des
nato-außenministertreffens in Brüssel
ein Statement des ukrainischen
Außenministers Kollege und werden wenn
es losgeht dorthin schauen jetzt aber
erst noch mal hier eine Kurzintervention
von Clara Bünger das ist nicht der
Bahnhof also ich glaube sie waren selber
noch nicht vor Ort sie müssten sich das
mal anschauen so eine Einrichtung und
ich habe es ja auch gesagt dass es die
erste Einrichtung hier in Berlin unter
bei der unter einem Dach alle
Hilfsorganisationen zusammenarbeiten und
die Koordination von funktioniert sehr
gut und ich denke Sie sollten sich da
mal hinbegeben und das Anschauen und das
sollte ein Vorbild sein auch für andere
Länder vielleicht wäre das ja mal ein
Hinweis für Sie an dieser Stelle
und Nadine schön die Möglichkeit zu
antworten
Frau Kollegin ich habe ein riesen
Respekt vor dem was in Berlin geleistet
wird das ist eine
riesenkraftanstrengung die vor allem von
Ehrenamtlern geleistet wird auch von der
Berliner Landesregierung auch von
Organisationen die hier unterstützen und
helfen ist eine riesen gemeinsame
kraftanströmung aber auch in Berlin sagt
man wir brauchen mehr Unterstützung von
dieser Bundesregierung in allen
Bereichen und deshalb erwarte ich von
dieser Bundesregierung dass sie nicht
nur das aufzählt was in der
Vorgängerregierung auf den Weg gebracht
worden ist sondern um gemeinsam mit
Ländern und Kommunen konkret helfen und
das gilt gerade für den Bildungsbereich
aber eben auf ja alle anderen Themen und
dieser Antrag ist unser erster Vorschlag
vor allem für die innenpolitischen
Themen aber sie können sich auch im
Familien- und Bildungsbereich gerne an
unseren Vorschlägen bedienen
und der letzte Redner in der Debatte
Mohammad alhalag FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Frau Präsidenten sehr
geehrter Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Kriegsbilder aus der Ukraine machen uns
alle fassungslos auch bei mir kommen
Bilder aus meiner eigenen Kindheit
wieder hoch die ich gerne vergessen
hätte ich weiß was es bedeutet von einem
Tag auf den anderen alles hinter sich zu
lassen was ist bedeutet vor Gewalt ins
Unbekannte zu fliehen ich weiß aber auch
was es bedeutet anzukommen und
aufgenommen zu werden und zwar bedeutet
es Zugang zu Bildung Zugang zu Arbeit
und Teilhabe an der Gesellschaft den
Schutz und Sicherheit bedeutet auch das
Gefühl der Ohnmacht bekämpfen Teil der
Gesellschaft zu sein und nicht nur eine
verwaltungsnummer Schutz und Sicherheit
bedeutet die Chance zu erhalten das
eigene Leben wieder in die Hand zu
nehmen
alles möchte ich an dieser Stelle um
missverständlich betonen die Notlager
von geflüchteten Menschen auszunutzen
ist ekelerregend erbärmlich und zu tief
zu verachten meine Damen und Herren der
Union
aber dass sie mit ihren an
trag erwecken dass die Bundesregierung
untät die massenweise Frauen Kinder und
Jugendlicher von Menschenhändlern
abgegriffen werden es schlicht unwahr
und unverschämt Frauen und Mütter die
vor der Vernichtung zu uns fliehen sind
nicht einfach Opfer sie sind Löwinnen
sie hatten vor einem Monat noch ein
selbstbestimmtes Leben einen Alltag
jetzt verteidigen sie ihr eigenes Leben
und das ihre Kinder und die
Bundesregierung und unser Staat steht
dabei an ihre Seite
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
cdu/cs die Möglichkeit haben sie ja in
ihren Antrag gehabt der Schutz von Leib
und Leben steht dabei natürlich an
erster Stelle doch direkt danach muss
das ermöglichen von Chancen für ein
selbstbestimmtes Leben stehen aber eines
bleibt klar dass Menschenwelt dass sie
in ihren Antrag zeichnen greift zu kurz
es ist nicht mein Bild vom geflüchteten
etwas wird auch deutlich bei einem Punkt
der mir persönlich sehr wichtig ist denn
ehrenamtlichen Helfern sie betonen die
Hilfsbereitschaft der Deutschen in
dieser Situation dem können wir alle in
diesem Saal sicherlich nur zustimmen
aber ich sage Ihnen auch schauen Sie mal
hier ein paar Meter nur 100 paar 100 m
weiter Richtung Hauptbahnhof schauen Sie
wie viele dieser ehrenamtlichen selbst
erst vor wenigen Jahren zu uns
geflüchtet sind es sind oftmals diese
Menschen die jetzt etwas zurückgeben es
sind Menschen die über alle Sprachen und
Kulturunterschiede hinweg einfach nur
helfen wollen und Menschlichkeit zeigen
jeder Mensch in Not der gehäufte dem
geholfen wird ist ein Gewinn für uns
alle wenn sie konstruktiv diesen
begleiten wollen verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Union da muss dabei
mehr rumkommen als im vorliegendem
Antrag vielen Dank
Johannas war das für die FDP-Fraktion
der hier das letzte Wort hatte zum
Antrag der Union
wir kommen
also bei mir hat sich jetzt kein PGF
gemeldet
und sie hatten nun schon drei
kurzinterventionen wie ich gerade gehört
habe oder zwei sie nicht
also ich sag mal grundsätzlich wir
lassen hier ja sehr viel zu es ist aber
keine Selbstverständlichkeit also das
ist schon klar nun hatte ich das
natürlich vorher nicht gesagt dass wir
schon lange nachhängen und so deswegen
lasse ich das jetzt einmal zu aber das
geht nicht dass sie sagen wir hatten
doch hier die Hand gehoben und das dann
geht das so also jetzt bitteschön
frau Präsidentin dann darf ich mich
zunächst einmal sehr herzlich dafür
bedanken dass Sie meine
zwischenintervention zulassen aber es
ist mir ein wirkliches Bedürfnis diese
Worte des Kollegen so nicht stehen zu
lassen ich glaube wir sind alle hier
geneigt einen politischen Wettbewerb
auch zu führen und um die besten Wege
und Lösungen zu ringen das ist Aufgabe
dieses Parlamentes aber unserem Antrag
unter stellen zu wollen wir würden das
Schicksal dieser Menschen der
Flüchtlinge die zu uns kommen ausnutzen
wollen um daraus parteipolitisches
Kapital zu schlagen das ist wirklich
unter aller Würde dieses Hauses
also wir sind alle beeindruckt und das
nehme ich für das gesamte Haus hier an
dass die Menschen in Not sind dass sie
traumatisiert zu uns kommen und dass wir
darum ringen hier diesen Menschen zu
helfen und es ist der FDP wirklich
unwürdig eine einer anderen
demokratischen Fraktion solch eine
solche Motivation unterstellen zu wollen
das weiß ich entschieden zurück
Herr Kollege sie können antworten sie
müssen nicht
bitte schön
bleiben Sie bitte stehen Herr Kollege
danke
natürlich habe ich den Eindruck erweckt
und Zuschauer gesehen in Brüssel geht es
los der ukrainische Außenminister der
Kollege nach dem Treffen der
NATO-Außenminister
so wir kommen nun zum Antrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache 133
die Fraktion der cdu/csu wünscht
Abstimmung in der Sache die Fraktion SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP wünschen
Überweisung und zwar federführend an den
Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat und
somitberatung an den Auswärtigen
Ausschuss den Rechtsausschuss den
Haushaltsausschuss an den Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales den Ausschuss für
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend den
Verkehrsausschuss den Ausschuss für
Bildung Forschung und Technik Folgen
Abschätzung den Ausschuss für die
Angelegenheiten der Europäischen Union
und an den Ausschuss für Wohnen
Stadtentwicklung Bauwesen und Kommunen
wir stimmen nach ständiger Übung zuerst
über den Antrag auf
Ausschussüberweisung ab wer stimmt für
die beantragte Überweisung
das ist DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP wer stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu wer enthält sich die AFD damit
ist die Überweisung so beschlossen damit
stimmen wir heute über den Antrag auf
Drucksache 1335 nicht in der Sache ab
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 8
Beratung des dritten
gleichstellungsberichts der
Bundesregierung für die Aussprache wurde
eine Dauer von 68 Minuten beschlossen
ich bitte Sie die Plätze schnell zu
wechseln damit wir zügig weitermachen
können
und
die Aussprache eröffnet die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin Ekin
deligös für die Bundesregierung
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen und
Kollegen vor uns liegt der dritte
Gleichstellungsbericht mit dem
Schwerpunkt Digitalisierung in diesem
Bericht kann man vier Kernpunkte
rauslesen der erste Punkt ist wir müssen
unsere Einstellung unseren Blick auf die
Dinge verändern und dazu gehört dass
Frauen in der Digitalisierung mehr
mitgestalten können müssen und das
Digitalisierung auch eine Chance für
Gleichstellung ist und dazu wir aber
mehr Frauen den Weg in den Bereich der
IT-Berufe ebnen müssen und diese
zusätzliche Chance zu nutzen um
Gleichstellung in diesem Land
voranzubringen
[Applaus]
mit der Digitalisierung worüber wir hier
reden gehen wir in der vierte
industrielle Revolution die entwickelt
sich aber weit schneller als die
bisherigen Revolution und sie ist nicht
nur Vierer Sandra sondern sie hat auch
einen anderen Charakter und gerade
deshalb ist es ja auch eine Chance und
übrigens auch der Bedarf da dass wir das
nicht einfach nur an uns vorbeiziehen
lassen wie ein rasenden ICE sondern das
wird auch Maßstäbe setzen dass wir
Standard setzen dass wir Bedingungen
dafür setzen und genau das sagen uns
auch die Sachverständigen in der dritten
dritten Gleichstellungsbericht sie sagen
nutzt diese Chance die Expertinnen und
Experten um Frau Professorin Yolo Talk
sie haben im letzten Jahr dieses
Gutachten für den Gleichstellungsbericht
vorgelegt 200 Seiten
101 Handlungsempfehlungen und ich freue
mich sehr dass dieser Bericht heute den
Bundestag und später auch sie im
Ausschuss erreichen wird
und eins begleitet uns bei der ganzen
Geschichte eigentlich andauernd es sind
zu wenige Frauen in den IT-Berufen es
sind zu wenige Frauen in den technischen
Berufen es sind zu wenige Frauen in den
Studiengängen und Ausbildungsgängen zu
diesen Berufen und das müssen wir
dringend ändern und genau das gehen wir
auch mit zu einem Bericht und mit Licht
in dem wir da reinwerfen und aufklären
und die Daten darstellen auch mit ein
wir im Ministerium
haben da auch schon einige Projekte die
wir fortführen die wir neu auf den Weg
bringen die wir voranbringen dazu gehört
nach wie vor Girlsday und sie alle als
Abgeordnete sind mit aufgerufen damit zu
machen denn auch unser Beruf als
Politikerin Politiker ist leider kein
typischer Frauenberuf auch da gehört das
dazu oder dass die Code Girls darum da
geht es möglichst niedrigschwellig das
Coding jungen Mädchen nicht nur
beizubringen sondern sie zu ermuntern
einfach mitzumachen und das nicht den
Jungs zu überlassen wir unterstützen
Frauen in den KI Berufen in der
ki-branche darin eigene Lösungen zu
finden und zu unterstützen denn gerade
die künstliche Intelligenz hat diesen
anderen Blickwinkel auch den weiblichen
Blickwinkel mehr als notwendig denn
Algorithmen sind nicht
geschlechtsneutral Algorithmen sind
können
Algorithmen können Frauen ausschließen
und diese Ungleichheiten multiplizieren
sich gleichmaßen wenn wir das ganze sich
selbst überlassen und verstärken das
ganze deshalb wollen wir das Frauen in
der KI nicht zusätzlich diskriminiert
werden wenn es darum geht ein Job zu
kriegen oder ein Kredit für einen
Start-up in diesem Land das kann mir
übrigens auch nicht national lösen das
müssen wir international angehen und
deshalb begrüßen wir vom Haus aus sehr
dass EU-Kommission mit der ki-verordnung
einen Vorschlag macht um die Qualität
und die Sicherheit der Nutzung von
Algorithmen zum Beispiel bei der
Personalauswahl
voranzubringen das Frauenministerium
arbeitet hier sehr stark in der
internationalen Vernetzung und wir
machen das auch nicht alleine sondern
wir machen das gemeinsam mit dem
Wirtschaftsministerium und das ist gut
so denn das ist nicht nur ein Thema für
das Frauenministerium sondern auch ein
wirtschaftlicher Aspekt und Punkt in
diesem Land
Frauen sollten ganz selbstverständlich
in der IT-Branche arbeiten können in
diesem berufen sie sollten Ihre
Expertisen ihren Blickwinkel ihre
Lebenserfahrung mit reinbringen und
damit verhindern wir
diskriminierungspotenzial nicht nur in
der IT-Branche sondern in der gesamten
Gesellschaft
tun wir
dafür zu
Führung Frauen übrigens auf allen Ebenen
und wir brauchen auch ein Kapital in der
digitalwirtschaft damit wir das ganze in
dem Bereich voranbringen können in der
bundesweiten gründerinnenagentur
arbeiten wir genau da dran all diese
Punkte umzusetzen
die Digitalisierung ist im vollen Gang
ich habe vorhin von einem ICE in voller
Fahrt geredet und jetzt ist es an der
Zeit auch die richtigen Weichen zu
setzen und
die Zwischenrufe von den Kollegen sollen
mich irgendwie glaube ich aus dem
Konzept rausfliegen aber das ist
irgendwie auch ein Teil des
Systems dass man genau das nicht macht
sondern dran bleibt dran bleibt an der
Gleichstellung dran bleibt die Themen
voranzubringen auch dran bleibt auch
dann diese Diskussion zu führen wenn sie
einem Teil des Hauses überhaupt nicht
gefallen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
brauchen drei Sachen wir brauchen Mut
wir brauchen Wille und wir brauchen auch
Geld um das voranzubringen über das
letztere werden wir im
Haushaltsverfahren reden über die
ersteren beiden Sachen müssen wir schon
heute und hier starten und übrigens
gerade als Politikerin in diesem Raum
müssen wir das auch immer wieder
verteidigen und dieser Beispiel ist das
Beste um das noch mal zu unterstreichen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
als nächste Rednerin erhält das Wort für
die cdu/csu-fraktion die Kollegin Nadine
schön
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
84% der Beschäftigten in der IT-Branche
in Deutschland sind Männer 84%
gerade einmal zwei von zehn Start-ups
werden von Frauen gegründet
und selbst wenn der Zugang gelingt
verlassen mehr als 50% der Frauen die
digitalbranche wieder im Top-Management
findet man sehr wenig Frauen auch in
diesem Bereich
und nur 13 Prozent der
informatikprofessuren an deutschen
Universitäten sind mit Frauen besetzt
das sind erschreckende Zahlen die im
Gleichstellungsbericht der
Bundesregierung gut aufgearbeitet sind
und diese Zahlen machten deutlich
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit
Chancengerechtigkeit ist in der
digitalbranche ein Problem und zwar ein
gewaltiges und das hat Konsequenzen das
hat zum einen wirtschaftliche
Konsequenzen denn wir alle wissen
diversität ist ein wichtiger Faktor für
den Unternehmenserfolg das haben
zahlreiche Studien bewiesen und egal in
welches Unternehmen ich komme Thema
Nummer eins ist der Fachkräftemangel vor
allem im innovativen Mittelstand und bei
Start-ups sagt man dass man gerade im
digitalen Bereich viel zu wenig
Fachkräfte findet und dann frage ich
mich schon wie wir uns den Luxus
erlauben können auf die Hälfte der
Bevölkerung nahezu zu verzichten
es ist aber auch gesellschaftlich ein
Problem denn durch die Digitalisierung
ändert sich unser ganzes Leben und dann
kann es uns doch nicht
egal sein dass die Frauen daran so wenig
beteiligt sind und auch das arbeitet der
Gleichstellungsbericht gut auch vor
allem was es heißt wenn
digitale wenn ki-systeme aus Daten
lernen die ein bias haben was dazu führt
dass Ungerechtigkeiten aus der
Vergangenheit auch auf die Zukunft
übertragen werden und der
Gleichstellungsbericht bringt da sehr
plastisch sehr gute Beispiele und
deshalb bedanke ich mich ganz herzlich
an bei Prof dr Jule tok und ihrer
Kommission für die wichtige Arbeit dass
sie dieses Thema so umfassend
aufgearbeitet haben
ich will aber drei Anmerkungen machen
die mir auch wichtig sind Anmerkung
Nummer eins
ich finde es schade dass der wirklich zu
wenig darauf eingeht welche Chancen den
Digitalisierung für Emanzipation für
Gleichberechtigung für Partizipation hat
Digitalisierung kann auch ein Treiber
dafür sein wenn man es richtig macht
wenn man die Weichen richtig stellt und
das kommt in meinen Augen in diesem
Bericht ein bisschen zu kurz
das zweite
mehr Geschlechtergerechtigkeit in der
digitalen Welt ist nicht nur eine
politische Aufgabe es ist eine
gemeinsame Aufgabe von Wirtschaft
Zivilgesellschaft Wissenschaft und
Politik und aus diesem Grund haben wir
auch im vergangenen Jahr oder vor
anderthalb Jahren die Initiative Ski
transforms it gegründet mit
Kolleginnen von allen demokratischen
Fraktionen mit Wirtschaft Wissenschaft
und Zivilgesellschaft und dieser
Initiative steht schon vom it können
sich alle anschließen haben sich auch
schon viele tolle Menschen angeschlossen
Männer wie Frauen die sagen der Zustand
den wir jetzt haben dann können wir so
nicht lassen wir müssen gemeinsam daran
arbeiten dass es besser wird und auf
diese gemeinsamen Initiativen müssen wir
auch in Zukunft setzen ich ermuntere
alle sich dem anzuschließen
aus dem Grund haben wir auch die
gleichstellungsstiftung des Bundes ins
Leben gerufen die unter anderem ganz
explizit im Gesetz genau diesen Auftrag
auch hat eben diese digitalen
Entwicklungen in den Blick zu nehmen und
hier dafür zu sorgen dass die derzeitige
Situation sich bessert und deshalb sage
ich es hilft nicht wenn wir mit dem
Finger aufeinander zeigen wir müssen das
Thema gemeinsam ange
hen und gemeinsam angehen heißt auch
nicht nur dass wir jetzt irgendwie noch
mal eine Regulierung schaffen und neue
Gesetze und neue Vorschriften gemeinsam
angehen heißt auch dass wir mal auch als
Gesetzgeber ganz kritisch hinterfragen
müssen ob wir nicht auch Gesetze haben
die in der digitalen Welt an Bedeutung
verloren haben oder sogar
kontraproduktiv sind beispielsweise das
Mutterschutzgesetz das
Mutterschutzgesetz sieht vor dass nach
20 Uhr nicht mehr gearbeitet werden darf
als Schwangere
oder als oder kurz nach der Geburt und
nur bis 22 Uhr mit Genehmigung der
Behörde das passt überhaupt nicht zur
Lebensrealität einer Frau in der
digitalen Branche die vielleicht lieber
mittags ihre Auszeit braucht wenn sie
schwanger ist oder morgens und die
abends sehr gut am Schreibtisch aus am
PC arbeiten kann diese Flexibilität ist
in dem Fall förderlich und wir behindern
sie durch unsere Regulierung die gut
gemeint war aber aus einer Zeit kam wo
wir eher die Fabrikarbeiterinnen im
Blick hatten und die auf manche Sachen
einfach nicht mehr passt
[Applaus]
wir müssen den Blick weiten wir müssen
auf digitale Bildung setzen in allen
Ländern damit wir schon früh die Mädchen
wie die Jungs gleichermaßen von den
tollen Möglichkeiten der Digitalisierung
begeistern und sie dann automatisch Lust
haben in diesem Bereich tätig zu sein
wir setzen auf die tollen Projekte you
could Girls ist genannt worden viele
mintinitiativen aus dem bildungsbildung
Bildungs- und Forschungsministerium und
viele Organisationen die sich genau um
diese Themen verdient machen gerade auch
Start-ups und der und und Initiativen
wie die wie die hackerschool
beispielsweise
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass Frauen
Finanzierung bekommen wenn sie den Mut
haben zu gründen das ist bisher nicht
der Fall auch das zeigt der Bericht und
vor allem müssen wir Vorbilder schaffen
Janina Kugel hat er mal gesagt wenn wir
erfolgreiche Frauen mehr Sichtbarkeit
verleihen sehen Mädchen dass Ihnen alle
Berufe offen stehen und das gilt ganz
besonders für den Digitalbereich und
deshalb haben alle eine Verantwortung
auch in den Podien in den Kongressen im
Bundestag in der Politik in der
Wirtschaft für Sichtbarkeit zu sorgen
und daran können alle mithelfen danke
[Applaus]
und die nächste Rednerin in dieser
Debatte ist Josefine Ortlepp für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren vor zwei Jahren hat es
in Deutschland hat in Deutschland der
erste Supermarkt eröffnet bei dem es
keine Kassiererinnen mehr gibt gezahlt
wird einfach per App geöffnet ist der
Laden rund um die Uhr für viele Menschen
ist es praktisch sie können spontan
einkaufen und brauchen eine App auf dem
Handy für Supermärkte ist das günstig
sie sparen sich das Personal doch für
uns als Gesellschaft bedeutet dieser
technologische Wandel soziale
Veränderungen und Umbrüche vor allen
Dingen für die Frauen und für die
Gleichberechtigung in Deutschland und
für uns bedeutet das hier im Hohen Hause
wir müssen ganz genau hinschauen bleiben
wir bei dem Beispiel mit dem
kontaktlosen Supermarkt der Job an der
Kasse wird eben oft von Frauen gemacht
und was passiert mit diesen Frauen wenn
ihre Kraft durch Geräte oder Computer
ersetzt wird oder was passiert mit der
älteren Kundin für die das Plaudern an
der Kasse häufig der einzige menschliche
Kontakt am Tag ist denn wer glaubt der
digitale Wandel sei Geschlechtern
neutral der liegt falsch der dritte
Gleichstellungsbericht zeigt uns genau
das auf dank der guten Arbeit der
unabhängigen
Sachverständigenkommission sehen wir die
vielen Dimensionen der Ungerechtigkeit
und was sich dringend ändern muss
die wichtigste Erkenntnis aus meiner
Sicht ist folgende einerseits spiegelt
die digitale Welt die Machtverhältnisse
unserer Gesellschaft wieder andererseits
schafft sie auch neue Realitäten die
digitale Welt und die reale Welt
beeinflussen sich gegenseitig das heißt
für uns als SPD-Bundestagsfraktion wir
müssen weiter daran arbeiten Strukturen
aufzubrechen die für Ungerechtigkeiten
in unserer Gesellschaft sorgen
nur so schaffen wir gleichberechtigte
Teilhabe in der Technologie entwickeln
bei der Verteilung von Arbeitsplätzen
oder bei der Nutzung von sozialen Medien
zweitens müssen wir erkennen wenn die
Digitalisierung Ungerechtigkeiten
verfestigt oder sogar verschärft denn
Diskriminierung werden häufig in
Algorithmen festgeschrieben und
sozusagen in Computersprache übersetzt
wenn die meisten Entwickler in
Deutschland und Designer vor allen
Dingen auch von diesen Produkten
männlich sind dann gestalten Sie die
digitalen Produkte eben oft anhand ihrer
eigenen männlichen Lebenswelt deshalb
sollten wir Unternehmen verpflichten
ihre Algorithmen auf deren
Geschlechtergerechtigkeit zu prüfen
und wie das gelingen kann zeigt ein
Startup aus meinem Wahlkreis quant Pie
die mit ihrem mit ihrer Arbeit das Ziel
haben die Entscheidungen die von
Algorithmen getroffen werden für alle
nachvollziehbar zu machen das ist ein
erster Schritt und mit dieser
beeindruckenden Arbeit gelingt ist die
Gesellschaft gerechter zu machen und
wenn wir es jetzt noch schaffen dass der
Anteil von Frauen in solchen Start-ups
erhöht wird und mehr Frauen den Zugang
zu Risikokapital zu ermöglichen kommen
wir der Gleichberechtigung wieder ein
Stück näher deshalb ist es gut dass wir
uns vorgenommen haben Gründerinnen im
digitalsektor durch Stipendium zu
stärken auch bei der Verteilung von
öffentlichen Geldern die in die
digitalbranche fließen müssen wir
Gleichstellung immer mitdenken
und natürlich müssen wir daran arbeiten
dass Mädchen und junge Frauen sich
informatikberufe zutrauen ich denke wir
sind uns einig wie wichtig es ist dass
Programme wie der Mint Aktionsplan und
die Bundesinitiative klischeefrei
weitergeführt werden wir dürfen aber
auch die vielen Frauen in den prekären
Arbeitsverhältnissen Verhältnissen nicht
aus dem Blick verlieren sie verdienen
wenig leisten aber so viel und sichtbare
Arbeit dazu gehört die alleinerziehende
Mutter die ihre Putzkraft auf einer
Internetplattform anbietet oder die
junge Studentin die Online
Nachhilfestunden gibt denn viele
Dienstleistungen Kinderbetreuung
Haushaltshilfe Sprachunterricht
verschieben sich immer stärker in den
digitalen Raum Jobangebote werden von
Nutzern online gestellt und
selbstständig organisiert das macht zwar
viele Frauen flexibel aber es bestehen
auch wirklich gefahren die Gefahr dass
die rechtliche und soziale Absicherung
nicht mehr greift die Frauen hangeln
sich von Auftrag zu Auftrag und können
es sich einfach nicht leisten krank zu
werden kranke Kinder zu betreuen oder in
den Urlaub zu fahren wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass auch auf digitalen
Plattformen gute und faire
Arbeitsbedingungen herrschen
auch die Online-Bewertungen die auf
Internetplattformen geschrieben werden
und Kommentare die in den sozialen
Medien gepostet werden sind ein Problem
hier erleben Frauen Hass Hetze und
Sexismus
manche ziehen sich komplett aus dem
Internet zurück dagegen müssen wir mit
guten beratungsstrukturen und
informierten Behörden ankämpfen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen was der
Bericht der Sachverständigenkommission
klar macht gleicher Zugang für Frauen
gleiche Nutzungsmöglichkeiten für Frauen
gleiche Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten für
Frauen das muss immer und überall gelten
und zwar gleichermaßen für den
Arbeitsmarkt das Lernen Ausbildung die
Finanzwirtschaft aber eben auch digitale
Plattformen einfach immer und überall
denn Gleichstellungspolitik ist auch
gerechtigkeitspolitik das gilt für die
analoge wie auch die digitale Welt und
dafür müssen wir kämpfen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Josefine Ortlepp
als nächster Redner erhält das Wort
Thomas ehrhorn für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
geschätztes Publikum
Gleichstellungsbericht der
Bundesregierung
276 Seiten 276 Seiten geschworen möchte
man sagen 276 Seiten in denen man das
immer gleiche Märchen erzählt von der
diskriminierten Frau die in der heutigen
Gesellschaft nicht aus eigener Kraft in
der Lage ist in Chefetagen vorzudringen
die nicht aus eigener Kraft in der Lage
ist mit Digitalisierung fertig zu werden
wo die selbstverständlich auch bei
gleicher Arbeit nicht den gleichen Lohn
erhält und die Frage die sich auftut ist
die nach der Intention dahinter die
Frage quiwono wem nützt das darauf werde
ich noch kommen und selbstverständlich
gibt es Unterschiede zwischen Männern
und Frauen und diese Unterschiede sind
beweisbar sie zeigen sich zum Beispiel
in den völlig verschiedenen Präferenzen
die Männer und Frauen zum Beispiel bei
der Berufswahl unterschiedliche
Präferenzen bei den angestrebten
Studiengängen und ja es scheint auch
heute noch so zu sein dass es eine bei
Frauen eine andere Bereitschaft gibt zum
Beispiel nach der Geburt des zweiten
oder dritten Kindes nur noch in Teilzeit
zu arbeiten und das sind aber eben die
Ergebnisse freier eigener Entscheidungen
und diese Entscheidung haben dann
natürlich auch Auswirkungen auf die
eigene Karriere und die Bezahlung die zu
erwarten ist und genauso sieht es auch
die kanadische entwicklungspsychologin
Susan pinker die in ihren Studien
nachweist dass gerade in einer besonders
freien gerade in wohlhabenden
Gesellschaften die Unterschiede zwischen
Männern und Frauen die unterschiedlich
gesetzten Prioritäten besonders stark
hervortreten
sie allerdings scheinen all das was im
Leben passiert nur durch die von Ihnen
selbst
herbeifantasierten Benachteiligung
erklären zu wollen und der letzte Schrei
dabei ist scheinbar das sogenannte
gender kehrgab welches sie gerade
erfunden haben und da möchte ich Sie
doch mal fragen definieren Sie doch mal
was ist denn eigentlich häusliche
kehrarbeit der Reifen und Ölwechsel am
Familienauto ist das nicht vielleicht
auch kehrarbeit wie sieht es denn aus
wenn am Rasenmäher das Messer stumpf ist
und gewechselt und ausgebaut werden muss
ist das nicht vielleicht auch kehrarbeit
und wer macht das denn wie sieht es denn
aus wenn nach einem Sturmschaden mit der
Kettensäge in der Hand auf dem eigenen
Grundstück der Sturmschaden beseitigt
wird ist nicht vielleicht das auch
kehrarbeit und wer macht das und
erzählen Sie mir doch bitte nicht dass
diese Art von Arbeiten durch Frauen
erledigt werden aber er spielt auch gar
keine alle wer es am Ende macht weil
Familien weil Paare sehr wohl in der
Lage sind untereinander festzulegen wer
was besser kann wer etwas lieber macht
und wie man kehrarbeit dementsprechend
im eigenen Haushalt am besten aufteilt
und zwar ohne ihre einmischende
Belehrung
nein meine Damen und Herren was sie hier
eigentlich Vorhaben ist etwas ganz
anderes sie versuchen immer größeren
Teilen der Bevölkerung einzureden dass
sie auf irgendeine Weise benachteiligt
und diskriminiert werden sie versuchen
den Chor der blöden immer größer werden
zu lassen der das Lied von der eigenen
Benachteiligung immer lauter singt das
ist genau der Grund warum sie in diesem
Hause auch ein minderheitenheit
betreiben seit vielen Jahren der für die
Mehrheitsgesellschaft eigentlich
unerträglich ist nein sie versuchen ihr
Narrenschiff zu füllen mit den Menschen
die sie auf diese Weise manipulieren und
wenn Sie das dann erreicht haben soll
dieses Narrenschiff genau dorthin fahren
wo grün es immerhin Steuern wollte
nämlich direkt in den Sozialismus meine
Damen und Herren bedauerlich ist nur
eben dass viele erst merken werden was
sie hier getan haben wenn der Job und
die Ersparnisse weg sind die Steuerlast
bei 70 Prozent die Wohnung halten die
Regale Supermarkt leer geräumt vielen
Dank
können Sie bitte in der afd-fraktion
noch mal die Masken überprüfen dass Sie
auch wirklich über Mund und Nase sind
dass wir sehr nett und als nächstes
erhält das Wort die Nicole Bauer für die
FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen kennen sie
Tischen onaran Annabell Tennesse oder
Konstanze Buchheim sind in maßgebliche
mitgestalterin der digitalen Szene in
Deutschland konstante Buchheim die
Unternehmerin der ersten Stunde
deutscher digitalwirtschaft sie gründete
2009 ein Potentials eine vielfach
ausgezeichnete Personalberatung für
digitale Spitzenposition die Professoren
und zukunftsforschende einer Welt Tennis
eine der führenden Köpfe für nachhaltige
und digitale Bildung oder Tischen anaran
vernetzt in der Initiative digital women
digitale Gestalterinnen miteinander zu
vernetzen und dieses sichtbar zu machen
sie zeigt uns starke rollmodels und ist
selbst eines davon denn nur wer sichtbar
ist findet auch statt und genau deshalb
brauchen wir viel mehr weibliche
Vorbilder in der digitalen Szene
wird unsere Zukunft unseres Landes
gestaltet und das sollten Frauen
mitwirken mitentscheiden und
mitentwickeln mit nur 16% Frauenanteil
ist die digitalbranche weit davon
entfernt und deshalb bin ich froh dass
wir hier und heute mit dem dritten
Gleichstellungsbericht der
Bundesregierung zu diesem Thema
aufmerksam machen denn es ist Zeit etwas
zu verändern weibliche und vielfältiger
zu werden diversity schafft einfach mehr
Perspektiven Kreativität und bessere
Lösungsansätze nutzen wir also die
Chance für den digitalen Wandel
entwickeln wir die besten Lösungen für
Zukunftstechnologien und bleiben wir
international wettbewerbsfähig Frauen
sind der Business Case meine Damen und
Herren
also was können wir tun erstens auf
frühe mintbildungssätzen und einen
Kulturwandel wir wissen das
geschlechtsspezifische Stereotypen
bereits im Alter von sechs Jahren
verinnerlicht werden deshalb gilt es
früh anzusetzen und mit Programme in der
frühkindlichen Bildung zu verankern und
ich weiß es selbst wie prägen das ist
als Mädchen den technischen Zugang
ermöglicht zu bekommen und so fand ich
auch persönlich meinen Weg in einen
mint-beruf als Ingenieurin und deckte
meine Leidenschaft für Innovation leider
mit viel zu wenigen Frauen um mich herum
vor allem wenn es im Karriereweg weiter
nach oben ging deshalb brauchen wir
einen Kulturwandel für mehr Frauen auf
Top Management Ebene und die
Zauberformel lautet dabei nicht fix so
wenn man sondern Fix für company
zweitens brauchen wir viel mehr Frauen
in techgründungen denn noch Gründen
Frauen wesentlich weniger und auch noch
erkennen Investoren nicht das Potenzial
der Frauen wegen unbewusster Vorurteile
und veraltete Rollenbilder unser Ziel
muss es sein berufliches
Selbstverständnis der Frauen zu haben
ihre Selbstverwirklichung voranzutreiben
in der digitalen Branche ein Fernzugang
zu gründungs- und Wagniskapital zu
schaffen und wir brauchen viel mehr
Business Angels all das haben wir in
unserem Koalitionsvertrag und wir werden
wirklich gut beraten wenn wir dies in
die Tat umsetzen und drittens brauchen
wir viel mehr freie Individualität und
eine moderne Arbeitswelt denn nicht nur
die corona-pandemie hat gezeigt wie
wichtig es ist mehr berufliche
Flexibilität zu haben um Erwerbsarbeit
umkehrarbeit unter einen Hut zu bringen
zeitlich örtlich unabhängiges mobiles
Arbeiten hilft dabei selbstverständlich
ist es nicht automatisch dass deshalb
die unbezahlte sorgearbeit besser
zwischen den Geschlechtern aufgeteilt
wird doch es schafft eine neue
Möglichkeit auch innerhalb der
Partnerschaft die gender carshare neu zu
verhandeln
machen wir uns klar und verabschieden
wir uns ganz klar von überholter
präsenzkultur:innen Unternehmen
veralteten Rollenbildern und Vorurteilen
meine Damen und Herren
und drittens
eine Sache liegt mehr als Liberale ganz
besonders am Herzen wenn wir heute über
Digitalisierung sprechen nämlich die
geschlechtsbezogene digitale Gewalt
entschlossen zu bekämpfen jeden Tag
erleiden Mädchen und Frauen digitale
Straftaten laut weltmädchen bricht 2020
vom Plan International sind es 58
Prozent der Mädchen in Deutschland sogar
70% der Mädchen die Bedrohungen
sexistischen Kommentaren und
Beleidigungen und Diskriminierungen im
Netz ausgesetzt sind
das schüchtert ein und viele Schweigen
danach das dürfen wir nicht zulassen
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und genau deshalb ist es für uns als
Freie Demokraten klar und eine besondere
Herzensangelegenheit auch die
istanbul-konvention im Schutz für
Mädchen und Frauen im digitalen Bereich
umzusetzen überlassen wir diesen Bereich
nicht nicht den Hetzern und Hatern
ja die Digitalisierung hat Chancen und
Herausforderungen zugleich die digitale
Transformation eröffnet neues Spielräume
in der Arbeitswelt im allgemeinen im
persönlichen Aufstieg in der
Work-Life-Balance in der fernen
geschlechterverwirklichung und eines
klar wir fürchten nicht diesen
Fortschritt sondern wir wollen ganz klar
den gemeinsam gestalten Männer und
Frauen gemeinsam herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
es folgt für die Fraktion Die Linke die
Kollegin Heidi Reicheneck
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen als Mitarbeiterin der
Jugendhilfe habe ich mit zahlreichen
Mädchen und jungen Frauen gesprochen und
vor allem auch über ihre Erfahrungen in
den sozialen Medien und das hat mich oft
entsetzt ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel
noch sehr gut an ein Mädchen das
eindeutig untergewichtig war und sich
trotzdem zu dick fand weil ihr der
Algorithmus immer neue verzerrte Bilder
vorgesetzt hat dazu muss man wissen 95
Prozent der 10 bis 18-Jährigen nutzen
soziale Medien die Nutzungsdauer hat
sich seit Beginn der corona-pandemie
sogar verdoppelt und dabei sehen junge
Menschen im Schnitt 5000 Bilder pro
Woche bewusst oder unterbewusst
vergleichen sich vor allem Mädchen und
junge Frauen mit Bildern die auf
retuschiert oder nachbearbeitet sind und
ein extrem schlechtes Körpergefühl
entwickeln vermitteln ganz zu schweigen
von den Beleidigungen den Frauen und
Mädchen online ausgesetzt sind laut dem
vorliegenden Gleichstellungsbericht wir
haben es gerade gehört werden 70% der
befragten Mädchen in Deutschland online
belästigt
auch hier erinnere ich mich leider an
viel zu viele Gespräche über die Folgen
dieser Belästigung Rückzug aus den
sozialen Medien Hilflosigkeit
Angststörungen obwohl der dritte
Gleichstellungsbericht mittlerweile über
ein Jahr alt ist sehr gute Lösung
präsentiert sehe ich leider bisher recht
wenig wo ist zum Beispiel die umfassende
Förderung von Vorbildern und positiven
Beispielen im Gegensatz zur letzten und
leider auch noch zu aktuellen Regierung
sind hier viele junge Menschen bereits
aktiv geworden es gibt beeindruckende
Accounts die Selbstakzeptanz Stärken
Austausch ermöglichen Unterstützung
anbieten all diesen Menschen möchte ich
an dieser Stelle einmal herzlichen Dank
dafür sagen dass sie sich das Internet
zurückerobern
aber auch die Medien schaffenden sind
hier in der Pflicht auch der Ausbau der
Medienbildung ist zentral das heißt vor
allem eine bessere strukturelle
Förderung der Jugendarbeit damit die
Kolleginnen dort besser auf die
Herausforderung der sozialen Medien
reagieren können und das Personal mit
den Kindern und Jugendlichen arbeiten
kann statt einen Antrag nach dem
nächsten zu verfassen und das hat die
Kollegin gerade sehr gut deutlich
gemacht es braucht klares Handeln gegen
digitale Gewalt überwachungs-apps das
Veröffentlichen von intimen Aufnahmen
oder online-stalking wir brauchen
endlich flächendeckende
Beratungsangebote und eine Stärkung von
Fachkompetenz vor allem bei Polizei und
Justiz am besten über verpflichtende
Weiterbildungen Frauenhäuser und
Beratungsstellen brauchen
IT-Unterstützung zum Beispiel durch gut
erreichbare it-kompetenzzentren die bei
Fragen digitaler gewalttechnisch
Unterstützung die To-Do-Liste ist lang
die letzte Regierung hat das leider
verschlafen die neue Koalition die sich
fortschrittskoalition nennt von der
erwarte ich ja einiges ich gebe ihnen
Vertrauensvorschuss verspielen sie den
nicht
die Digitalisierung hat aber seit Corona
auch unsere Arbeitswelt komplett
umgekrempelt die Arbeit im Homeoffice
führt zu Dauer Erreichbarkeit
Arbeitszeiten dehnen sich aus und
Ruhephasen werden aufgehebelt gerade
Frauen übernehmen im Homeoffice
zusätzlich auch noch mehr sorgearbeit
als sowieso schon ich erinnere kurz
Frauen haben bereits vor Corona 53% mehr
Zeit für Haus und sorgearbeit erbracht
als Männer bei Panik Kindern waren es
sogar 83 Prozent mehr die Schließung von
Kitas und Schulen hat zudem betreuungs-
und organisationsbedarf Stichwort
Homeschooling drastisch erhöht und wer
hat das größtenteils aufgefangen es wird
sie alle sehr überraschen es waren die
Frauen viele Frauen haben deswegen ihre
Arbeitszeit reduziert und ja auch Männer
haben das teilweise gemacht doch nach
zwei corona-jahren Arbeiten die Männer
jetzt wieder wie vorher während jede
fünfte Frau immer noch ihre Tätigkeit
reduzieren musste um unplanbaren
betreuungssituationen gerecht zu werden
und was haben wir nun davon vor allem
Mütter haben während der Pandemie das
Vertrauen in die Politik verloren es
wurde viel zu wenig getan um Familien
speziellen Mütter und Alleinerziehende
in den letzten zwei Jahren zu entlasten
stattdessen wieder ein Rückfall in alte
Muster man verdient Geld Frau kümmert
sich und wissen Sie was das besonders
perfide ist immer mehr noch nicht genug
Männer wollen auch Gleichstellung im
Privaten sie wollen die sorgearbeit
faire aufteilen aber stoßen wie Frauen
seit Jahrzehnten übrigens auch in der
Realität an ihre Grenzen deswegen muss
zum Beispiel endlich das
ehegattenspraying abgeschafft werden
statt mit einer solch pflegeleiteten
Politik weiter die traditionelle
Rollenverteilung zu zementieren wenn wir
uns mit Gleichstellung beschäftigen dann
müssen wir an den Kern der Problematik
Betreuungsangebote ausweiten soziale und
pflegerische Berufe in denen Frauen
klassisch überrepräsentiert sind endlich
mit besserer Bezahlung aufwerten
Minijobs nicht ausweiten wie sie planen
sondern sie in
vollsozialversicherungspflichtige Jobs
überführen aber natürlich können wir
stattdessen über einen Bericht
diskutieren der über ein Jahr alt ist
das hilft nur leider niemanden da
draußen der auf unsere Arbeit angewiesen
ist vielen Dank
sie müssen einfach schneller denken dann
verstehen Sie mich auch
[Applaus]
die nächste Rednerin für Bündnis 90 die
grüne ist Denise Lob und es ist ihre
erste Rede im Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen der demokratischen Parteien
die die zuhörer:innen wussten sie dass
biometrische Identifikationssysteme
weiße Menschen besser erkennen als
schwarze das promovierten Frauen der
Zugang zu Umkleide in Fitnessstudio
verehrt wurde weil das automatische
Zugangssystem den Doktortitel
ausschließlich Männern zuordnete
und das Stellenausschreibung für
LKW-Fahrer auf einer sozialen Plattform
vorrangig Männern angezeigt werden
während Anzeigen für Erzieher vorrangig
Frauen gezeigt werden
diese Beispiele aus dem dritten
Gleichstellungsbericht zeigen
Algorithmen führen bestehende
Geschlechter Stereotype fort und Sie
können Sie sogar verstärken
auch deshalb ist es ein großes Problem
dass nur 16 Prozent der Frauen in der
digitalbranche tätig sie kaum in dessen
Führungspositionen vertreten und sie
auch bei der Gründung von Start-ups
deutlich unterrepräsentiert sind in
anderen Worten Frauen sind an der
digitalen Transformation in diesem Land
nicht angemessen beteiligt
und das hat Einfluss auf die Entwicklung
von neuen digitalen Technologien denn
sie sind nie neutral sie sind immer in
gesellschaftlichen Machtverhältnissen
und Kontexten eingebettet
liebe Kolleginnen Digitalisierung hat
Auswirkungen und zwar ganz reale
Auswirkungen im Alltag und auf die
Teilhabechancen von Frauen und Mädchen
das sieht man zum Beispiel an der
Situation von Frauen im Homeoffice
während der Pandemie auf der einen Seite
kann das Arbeiten von zu Hause Chancen
bieten erwerbs- und sorgearbeit besser
zu vereinbaren auf der anderen Seite
zeigt sich aber das ist gerade die
Frauen sind die unbezahlte sorgearbeit
sehr viel stärker ausweiten im
Homeoffice als Männer das bedeutet auch
hier muss bei der Erarbeitung von
gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen die
Perspektive von Frauen sehr viel stärker
berücksichtigt werden
[Applaus]
eine weitere Realität ist Frauen sind
von digitaler Gewalt im Netz betroffen
und insbesondere dann wenn sie sich
antirassistisch und queerfeministisch
engagieren laut einer Studie wir haben
es jetzt heute schon mehrfach gehört vom
kleinen international Deutschland haben
70 Prozent der jungen Frauen in
Deutschland im Internet bereits
Bedrohung oder Gewalt erlebt und leider
bestätigen auch aktuelle Zahlen dass sie
sich deshalb aus dem öffentlichen
Diskurs zurückziehen das ist ein
demokratisches Problem das müssen wir
ändern frauen haben einen Recht darauf
auf eine gleichberechtigte und sichere
Teilnahme am öffentlichen Diskurs
digitale Gewalt müssen wir immer und
überall bekämpfen denn jede Form von
Diskriminierung der Frauen begünstigt
geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt
aus dem dritten Gleichstellungsbericht
lässt sich auch ein klarer Auftrag für
die Ampelkoalition aus ableiten deswegen
bin ich unser parlamentarisches
Staatssekretärin equin deligiös sehr
dankbar für ihre deutlichen Worte und
die Bitte diese wichtigen Themen auch im
Haushalt zu fahren
denn wir brauchen dieses Geld um die
Handlungsempfehlung des Berichts in der
ressortübergreifenden
gleichstellungsstrategie zu
berücksichtigen um die
Digitalisierungsstrategie um eine
geschlechtersensible Perspektive zu
erweitern und um mint-programme zu
fördern damit geschlechtstereotype und
Zugangsbarrieren für Frauen und Mädchen
in der IT-Branche abgebaut werden alle
diese Maßnahmen sind notwendig
[Applaus]
denn wir wollen doch alle in einer
Gesellschaft leben in der nicht nur die
technischen Aspekte sondern auch die
Menschen in ihrer gesamten Vielfalt
berücksichtigt werden wir wollen in
einer Gesellschaft leben in der sich
alle unabhängig vom Geschlecht sicher
diskriminierungsfrei und
gleichberechtigt an den digitalen
Transformationsprozessen beteiligen
damit alle Menschen gleichermaßen von
den vielen Chancen der Digitalisierung
profitieren vielen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank und als nächste Rednerin
hält das Wort die Kollegin Dr Katja
leikert für die cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eigentlich
müsste der Name Karin dorepal jedem ein
Begriffs sein sie hat im Jahr 2004
geschafft was noch keiner Frauen
Deutschland vorher gelungen war sie war
die erste Frau im Vorstand eines
DAX-Konzerns und von da an hat es lange
15 Jahre gedauert bis der nächste
Meilenstein tatsächlich dann erreicht
war mit Jennifer morgen bezog 2019 zum
ersten Mal eine Frau dass sie opero in
einem DAX-Konzern jetzt herrschen heute
nicht mehr die Verhältnisse von 2004
aber ein Frauenanteil in den
Vorstandsbüros der 200 größten
Unternehmen von gerade einmal 15 Prozent
zeigt dass die Chancengleichheit für
Frauen in vielen Unternehmen immer noch
Utopie ist und sehr geehrter Kollege
ehrhorn ob Sie es glauben oder nicht es
ist gar keine angeboren von Frauen nach
dem zweiten oder dritten Kind freiwillig
zu Hause zu bleiben oder nur halbtags zu
arbeiten und es ist die Aufgabe von uns
allen hier diese Zustände endlich zu
ändern
dennoch außerhalb der Vorstandsetagen
sieht es mit Frauen in der IT-Branche
mager aus 2021 lag der Frauenanteil in
Deutschland bei 18 Prozent in
informatik-studiengängen liegt der
Frauenanteil knapp bei einem Viertel auf
offene Positionen im Bereich
Programmierung und IT bewerben sich je
nach Position nur 10 bis 20 Prozent
Frauen im startup-umfeld ist es kaum
besser an der Gründung mit vorwiegend
digitalen Geschäftsmodellen und
Plattformen sind nicht einmal 16 Prozent
Frauen in den Gründungsteam verbreitet
und das liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
darf so nicht bleiben
viele dieser Entwicklungen stützt auch
der dritte Gleichstellungsbericht der
Bundesregierung den wir heute hier
beraten auf 276 Seiten liegt die
Sachverständigenkommission dar wo der
Handlungsbedarf für die Gleichstellung
von Frauen in der digitalbranche einer
digitalisierten Gesellschaft bestehen
und das ist im Jahr
2022 noch einen
276-seitigen Bericht zu dem Thema
braucht
veranschaulicht genau die große
Herausforderung vor der Frauen heute
stehen wenn sie im digitalen Kosmos Fuß
fassen wollen und diese Herausforderung
anzugehen und das sollten wir hier alle
gemeinsam tun müssen wir ein
zweischichtiges Problem angehen erstens
die Tatsache dass Frauen immer noch zu
selten in digitalen Jobs und
Studiengängen vertreten sind und
zweitens dass Frauen noch immer zu
selten in Führungspositionen zu finden
sind aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Arbeitgeber erinnern es sich schlichtweg
nicht leisten auf weibliche Fachkräfte
zu verzichten und was ist hier braucht
ist ein Dreiklang früh Aufmerksamkeit zu
schaffen Vorbilder aufzuzeigen und ja
liebe Männer auch Karrieren von Frauen
nicht im Weg zu stehen
es muss bereits in jungen Alter
Aufmerksamkeit für die mintberufe bei
Mädchen erzeugt werden
zielgerichtete Kampagnen wie u-code
Girls sind der eine von vielen
verpflichtende Angebote in Kitas und
Grundschulen und geschultes Personal
sind von großer Bedeutung und ganz
zentral sind natürlich auch Vorbilder
das wissen wir Frauen am allerbesten
weniger Klischees mehr rollmodels wir
brauchen weibliche Führungskräfte in
IT-Berufen die die Diversität in
Unternehmen erhöhen und ein
multiplikatoren-effekt haben
unbewusste Vorteile dass Dax-Vorstände
grauhaarige Anzugträger zu sein haben
müssen endlich der Vergangenheit
angehören
und was ist hier für braucht und es muss
auch im Jahr 2022 immer noch
angesprochen werden sind eben auch
Männer in Führungspositionen die diesen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Prozess offen
gegenüberstehen denn sie sind es
meistens die Einstellungen vornehmen und
Beförderung entscheiden meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ich könnte
jetzt noch weiter ausführen wie wichtig
genügend Kitaplätze sind und
Betreuungsangebote ganz unabhängig von
der Branche digital oder analog möchte
ich gerne die Bundesregierung dazu
auffordern sich weiter für den Ausbau
dieser Plätze einzusetzen sehr verehrte
Damen und Herren ich hoffe inständig
dass es
zukünftig keines fast 300 seitigen
Berichts mehr braucht um Frauen
gleichzustellen und das ist bald der
Vergangenheit angehört bitte lassen Sie
uns endlich PS auf die Straße bringen
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank
und als nächste Rednerin erhält das Wort
dr Caroline Wagner für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen guten Morgen
und falls wir uns heute nicht mehr sehen
guten Tag guten Abend und gute Nacht die
meisten von ihnen dürften jetzt das
grinsende Gesicht von Jim Carrey vor
Augen haben der im Film die Truman Show
der Star seiner eigenen Serie ist ohne
davon zu wissen wie sollte er auch
immerhin so die Story des Films ist der
29-Jährige Truman bereits als Baby in
das filmsetting quasi eingepflanzt
worden und dieses wurde immers
Wirklichkeit verkauft eine simulierte
Realität die zu prackeln beginnt als ihm
eines vermeintlich normalen Tages
plötzlich ein Scheinwerfer vom Himmel
vor die Füße knallt Truman beginnt
daraufhin zu zweifeln er schaut genau
hin und erkennt mehr und mehr dass das
was er als Wirklichkeit begriffen hatte
purerschein ist und er beginnt erbittert
dagegen anzukämpfen
ziemlich ähnlich gelagert ist die Frage
um die Gleichstellung denn strukturelle
Diskriminierung gegenüber Frauen in
unserer Gesellschaft ist ein Fakt Punkt
denn werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen vom
Geschlecht hängen natürlich zu ihnen
komme ich gleich noch vom Geschlecht
hängen natürlich zahlreiche
zahlreiche biologische Faktoren ab aber
vom Geschlecht hängen eben weder wissen
noch können Talent Know-how Neigung oder
Interesse ab aber ich sage auch ganz
klar dies ist die Ausgangsbasis für
Gleichstellungsarbeit und wer diese
Ausgangsbasis nicht teilt so wie ich es
heute ja schon in Wortmeldungen
herausgehört habe wer das nicht teilte
erkennt natürlich auch nicht den Sinn
und den Nutzen der Maßnahmen die
strukturelle Diskriminierung beseitigen
und wer das alles nicht sehen will der
Blick nur auf eine Kulisse wie sie die
Berge der Himmel und das Meer in der
tumin-show sind und das ist sehr sehr
tragisch in der konsequenzwerte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen denn diese
fallen ja deshalb nicht weg nur das
Problem nicht erkennt und wahrhaben will
und was ist die Konsequenz dieser
strukturellen Diskriminierung was ist
die Konsequenz dieser wirkt mächtigen
Rollen Klischees die ständig repliziert
werden die Konsequenz ist dass wir viele
Talente in diesem Land ungenutzt liegen
lassen ganz deutlich zeigt sich dies mit
einem Blick auf die IT und
Technikbranche 16 Prozent das ist der
Frauenanteil in der IT-Branche in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
18,5% sind es in der gesamten EU und das
wird gleich diese Branche eine
Zukunftsbranche ist und unsere
wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit und
Anschlussfähigkeit ganz erheblich davon
abhängen Digitalisierung und Informatik
voranzutreiben nun ist klar es können ja
im Beruf nur mindestens so viele Frauen
eingesetzt werden wie sich in der
entsprechenden Ausbildung auch begeben
also lassen Sie uns auf die Ingenieurs
und Informatikstudiengänge schauen der
Anteil an AbsolventInnen in der
abschlusskoordie liegt hierbei gerade 25
Prozent beziehungsweise 21 Prozent für
die Informatik und natürlich muss man
auch hier auf die vorherige Stufe der
Bildungsbiografie gucken auch als
Schulfach wird die Informatik von
Mädchen weniger häufig auf erhöhten
Anforderungsniveau gewählt als von
Lungen
und nun kann man sich aufgrund dieser
Datenlage aufgrund dieser Fakten auch
einfach ganz bequem zurücklehnen so wie
es der Herr Erhorn eben tut und sagen ja
mai das dürften doch dann die Frauen
selber wählen wird ihnen doch nicht
vorgeschrieben ob sie Informatik
studieren ja das stimmt vielleicht aber
es stimmt eben auch dass Frauen auf dem
Weg zu einem solchen Studium und somit
auf dem Weg zu einer Karriere in der IT
oder Technikbranche mit ungeheuer mehr
Hindernissen und Stolpersteinen
konfrontiert sind als ihre männlichen
Weggefährten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und
ja Herr Ehrmann den Wirkungszusammenhang
den Wirkungszusammenhang den kann ich
Ihnen auch noch erklären ja Mädchen
erfahren ganz früh das ist schon
irgendwie seltsam ist wenn Sie sich für
Technik interessieren wenn Sie gerne in
der Werkstatt tüfteln oder am
computerprogrammieren und es braucht
eine hohe innere Antriebskraft und
innere Stärke sich dieser spürbaren
Konfrontation zu entziehen und dran zu
bleiben am Interesse für Technik diese
Erfahrung machen viele Mädchen und junge
Frauen die sich für eine solche Laufbahn
entscheiden und deshalb ist es
unglaublich wichtig schon früh im
Bildungsprozess anzufangen mit dem Abbau
derartiger Rollenklischees und
Stereotype und deswegen sind Projekte
wieder Girls Day der Boys day der
nationale Pakt für Frauen in mint und
andere Maßnahmen zu wichtige Bausteine
auf dem Weg dorthin bei all diesen
Maßnahmen geht es darum Kindern
allgemein und im Speziellen Mädchen und
junge Frauen frühestmöglich abzuholen
sie zu ermutigen und zu unterstützen
solche Förderprogramme Maßnahmen und das
hebt eben die Bundesregierung und der
Sachverständigenrat im
gleichstellungsgutachten richtigerweise
hervor können gar nicht früh genug
ansetzen und diese Programme sie wirken
auch das weiß ich aus eigener Erfahrung
vor dem Antritt meines Mandats im Herbst
durfte ich an einer Technischen
Hochschule in der Oberpfalz ein solches
Förderprogramm für junge Frauen in mint
umsetzen ziel dieses Programms war die
Stärkung des mintinteresses von
SchülerInnen in der Abschlussphase und
beim Übergang zu einem Studium also
genau dann wenn die Gefahr besteht dass
es zum Bruch kommt mit dem eigentlichen
Interesse das bestärken dieser
SchülerInnen in ihrem mintinteresse ging
aber auch stark einher mit dem bewusst
machen
geschlechtsspezifischer wirktmechanismen
viele der Mädchen die bei diesem Projekt
mitgemacht hatten den knallt die ebenso
wie Truman Burbank irgendwann plötzlich
ein Scheinwerfer vor die Füße und sie
wurden sich bewusst wie ihre Umwelt auf
Sie als technikbegeisterte Mädchen
reagierte und was das auch mit eigenen
selbst wiederum machte diese erkennen
bestärkte viele von ihnen ihren Weg in
ein technisches Studium oder eine
technische Ausbildung auch wirklich
umzusetzen das also Projekte wie dieses
zur Verbesserung führen das sieht man
auch insgesamt an leichten anwüchsen
beim Anteil der Frauen in
mintstudiengängen es sind keine großen
Sprünge die sich hier zeigen aber der
Anteil wächst er wächst langsam aber er
wächst den immerhin geht es darum lange
institutionalisierte Muster und
Denkweisen in unserer Gesellschaft
aufzubrechen und das ist eben auch keine
leichte Aufgabe sondern ein langer Weg
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und auch
hierbei können wir uns ein Beispiel an
einer Frau aus der Naturwissenschaft
nehmen denn schon die zweifache
Nobelpreisträgerin für Chemie und Physik
Marie Curie sagte ich habe gelernt dass
der Weg des Fortschritts weder kurz noch
unbeschwerlich ist und gleiches gilt für
den Weg der Gleichstellung der
Geschlechter deshalb lassen wir uns aber
nicht aufhalten gehen wir weiter brechen
wir weiterhin
rollentwickys auf und entfesseln damit
viele Talente in diesem Land vielen
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank
ich möchte den Abgeordneten fahrle
bitten von der afd-
als nächste Rednerin erhält das Wort für
die afd-fraktion Mariana harder Kühnel
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren dieser Bericht
ist ein Paradebeispiel dafür wie
Steuergelder verschwendet werden
276 Seiten voller Ideologie 276 Seiten
voller hohler Phrasen über die
geschlechtergerechtegestaltung der
Digitalisierung über 100 sogenannte
Experten setzen sich mit
pseudophoblemen auseinander
388 mal ist von Gender die Rede und 827
mal von Gleichstellung
827 mal das ist geradezu obsessiv
sie wollen mit aller machtstunde auch in
der Digitalisierung die Gleichstellung
der Geschlechter durchsetzen wir
brauchen aber keine Gleichstellung im
Sinne von ergebnisgleichheit wir
brauchen viel mehr Gleichberechtigung im
Sinne von Chancengleichheit
Chancengleichheit muss
selbstverständlich gegeben sein das
bedeutet aber nicht dass man in allen
Bereichen und mit aller Macht ein
50%igen Anteil von Frauen erzwingen muss
sondern einfach dass es auch jeder Frau
möglich sein muss jeden Beruf zu
ergreifen den sie möchte
und wenn sich trotz Chancengleichheit
nur 16 Prozent der Frauen für eine
Karriere in der digitalbranche
entscheiden dann ist das ebenso
akzeptieren Sie einfach die
Unterschiedlichkeit der Geschlechter
lassen sie Frauen Frauen und Männer
Männer sein
mehr als jedes ideologisch versiffte
gleichstellungsprogramm würde Frauen
Wertschätzung helfen Wertschätzung für
das was wir sind und für das was sie
leisten zum Beispiel indem man die
Anerkennung ihrer Erziehungsleistungen
der Rente endlich schafft und wissen Sie
was im angeblich achso konservativen ach
so erzkatholischen Kohlen propagiert
kein übergriffiger Staat welche Rollen
man und frau in Familie Beruf oder eben
in der digitalen Welt zu spielen haben
das Ergebnis in Polen liegt der Anteil
von Frauen in Führungspositionen bei 44
Prozent im Bund diversen Deutschland nur
beachten 20 Prozent also nehmen Sie doch
bitte mal frauenpolitischen
Nachhilfeunterricht bei unseren
östlichen Nachbarn meine Damen und
Diskriminierung findet in Deutschland
zwar statt aber an ganz anderer Stelle
als in der digitalbranche
diskriminierend ist dass Frauen als
Dummchen darzustellen die es ohne
staatliche Quotenregelung zu nichts
bringen
diskriminierend ist es die
Lebensleistung von Frauen nur anhand
ihres Berufslebens zu messen wären ihr
Einsatz für Kinder und Familie
unberücksichtigt bleibt und wer sich den
Gleichstellungsbericht kritisch
durchliest der erkennt schnell dass die
dort angeführte angebliche
Diskriminierung nichts weiter ist als
ein Vorwand ein Vorwand für die von der
Ampel bereits auf allen Ebenen
praktizierte Transformation die
Transformation mit der man die
Gesellschaft umformen will um das eigene
ideologisch verblendete Weltbild zu
etablieren dass dies unter anderem
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss vorzulegen
soll
zeigt die Gefährlichkeit dieser
Regierung auf den Kinder sind keine
ideologischen Projekte sondern unsere
Zukunft vielen Dank
als nächste Rednerin erhält das Wort für
die FDP-Fraktion die Kollegin Katja
Adler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit nunmehr 14
Jahren erinnert der Equal Pay Day an den
langweg zu Entgeltgleichheit zwischen
Frauen und Männern der equal payday
zeigt jedes Jahr dass die
gleichstellungsdebatte nicht mehr nur
über die rechtliche Gleichstellung
geführt werden darf sondern über
tatsächlich gleiche
Verwirklichungschancen geführt werden
muss denn nun dritte
Gleichstellungsbericht der
Bundesregierung beschreibt die aktuelle
Situation von Frauen insbesondere im
Digitalbereich und gibt uns allen
Handlungsempfehlungen und Hausaufgaben
auf heute sind wir zwar gesellschaftlich
angesprochen und sensibilisiert weil
sich zum Beispiel unternehmerische
Erfolg nachweislich diversen Teams
besser einstellt als in homogenen Teams
dennoch werden gerade einmal 15,7
Prozent der Start-ups in Deutschland von
Frauen gegründet nur zehn Prozent der
Frauenteams erhalten Kapital von
Business Angels und nur acht Prozent
erhalten Risikokapital selbst bei
staatlichen Fördermitteln erhalten nur
21 Prozent der Frauenteams eine
Förderung und das obwohl Unternehmen die
von Frauen gegründet werden oftmals viel
nachhaltigeren Erfolg nachweisen können
und haben Frauen den Schritt in die
digitalbranche gewagt bleiben sie oft
nur kurz dort die hohefluktuation wirft
auch im Bericht ein Schlaglicht auf die
Arbeits- und Unternehmenskultur
verbreitetes Stereotype Vorstellung von
Frauen in einem männlich geprägten
Arbeitsumfeld und manche Elemente der in
diesem Unternehmen verbreiteten
Arbeitsmethoden werden als zentrale
Gründe dieser gering verweildau von
Frauen in der digitalbranche gesehen
schaffen wir also den Rahmen für einen
Wandel der Arbeits- und
Unternehmenskultur um mehr Frauen
langfristige Perspektiven zu bieten
verschaffen wir mehr Frauen Zugang zu
Finanzierung unzuförderung
helfen wir mehr Frauen zu mehr
Sichtbarkeit zeigen wir dass wir tolle
Frauen in der digitalen Branche haben
nur dies ist unser Weg zu dauerhaften
Erfolg und zur Konkurrenzfähigkeit auch
im europäischen Vergleich ein Wandel der
Arbeits- und Unternehmenskultur ist auch
bedingt durch ein Wandel unserer
gesellschaftlichen Kultur insgesamt denn
solange Mütter die neben ihrer Familie
auch ihre Karriere verfolgen als
Rabenmütter dargestellt werden haben wir
noch einen langen Weg vor uns hin zu
einem wirklichen Kulturwandel in unserer
gesamten Gesellschaft
für diesen Kulturwandel braucht es
mutigere Ansätze dafür braucht es alle
Menschen unserer Gesellschaft es braucht
Frauen die sich für eine Karriere im
Digitalbereich einstellen und es braucht
Männer die diesen Wandel aus voller aus
tiefer überzeugend mittragenen
also liebe Frauen liebe Männer seien wir
mutig und gehen wir gemeinsam voran
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und die nächste Rednerin ist Ullis
schaus für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieser dritte
Gleichstellungsbericht den debattieren
wie hier weil sich die Bundesregierung
es sich zur Aufgabe gemacht hat die
Erkenntnisse aus der
Geschlechterforschung ernst zu nehmen
seiner Handlungsempfehlungen in die
konkrete politische Arbeit einfließen zu
lassen und viele Empfehlungen stehen
schon im chorvertrag und auch im
Regierungsprogramm wie beispielsweise
Gewalt gegen Frauen die auch im
digitalen Raum ausgeübt wird hier muss
deutlich stärker gendersensibler Schutz
gewährleistet werden die Regierung
die Regierung setzt auf Synergien und
siedelt den kommenden
Gleichstellungsbericht in der neuen
Bundesstiftung Gleichstellung an das ist
gut das wird jetzt gemacht aber
Kolleginnen und Kollegen was nicht
vorhersehbar war das war die Pandemie
und ihre Auswirkungen und unter Corona
hat dieser dritte Gleichstellungsbericht
Digitalisierung geschlechtergerecht
gestalten besonders Aktualität bekommen
wir haben als Gesellschaft in der
Pandemie einen digitalisierungssprung
gemacht aber was nicht gelungen ist ist
geschlechtergerecht durch die
corona-krise zu kommen Frauen haben in
den letzten zwei Jahren zu oft und zu
lange bis zur Erschöpfung des Unmögliche
versucht Homeoffice Homeschooling
Haushalt alles gleichzeitig nicht wenige
die systemrelevant sind oder nicht im
Homeoffice arbeiten können und
gleichzeitig keine Kinderbetreuung zur
Verfügung haben kündigten ihren Job da
müssen wir ehrlich sein Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die besten Rahmenbedingungen
helfen Frauen nicht weiter wenn sie
nicht entlastet werden wenn es keine
Umverteilung von care-arbeit gibt und
vor allem
wenn nahezu erwartet wird dass die
Frauen ist schon irgendwie machen dass
sie zurückstecken nein wenn die digitale
Zukunft der Arbeit gestaltet wird ist es
zentral erwerbs- und sorgearbeit
zusammenzudenken wirksame Regelungen zu
schaffen und Kinder und Job
partnerschaftlicher aufzuteilen und die
Vorhaben der Ministerin Spiegel sind
hier gut und wichtig sie wurden gestern
im Ausschuss vorgestellt das gehen wir
jetzt an und ich freue mich auf die
Umsetzung dieser Maßnahmen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
als nächste Rednerin erhält für die
cdu/csu-fraktion die Kollegin Dorothee
Bär das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der dritte
Gleichstellungsbericht verbindet zwei
Querschnittsthemen auf der einen Seite
digitalisierungspolitik auf der anderen
Seite
Gleichstellungspolitik und wenn man auf
die Handlungsempfehlungen des Berichts
schaut sieht man sofort dass nicht nur
sämtliche Bundesministerien betroffen
sind sondern auch alle politischen
Ebenen angesprochen sind und wenn man
sich anschaut dass das ja jedes für sich
genommen schon eine wahnsinnige
Mammutaufgabe ist sind natürlich beide
zusammen erst recht und beide Themen
absolute herzensthemen von mir und ich
weiß dass wir in beiden Bereichen
schneller vorankommen müssen weil wir es
ganz besonders unseren Töchtern auch
schuldig sind und deswegen habe ich
nicht ganz verstanden Herr Erhorn Frau
harder kühne wie sie hier solche Reden
halten können sie haben im Kürschner
stehen dass sie auch Kinder haben ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob Töchter dabei sind
aber es ist schon etwas befremdlich und
ich frage mich ob sie sich morgen
überhaupt nach so einer Rede wieder in
ihre eigene Familie zurück trauen
im Mittelpunkt und ganz ehrlich sie
können froh sein dass das was sie alles
die ganze Zeit reden Unterhaltungen
untereinander sind wir sind ja dank der
FDP so nah dran dass wirklich auch die
privatunterhaltungen da tut einem alles
weh wirklich da gehen alle Haare
sträuben sich dazu Berge unterirdisch
was Sie hier alles von sich geben ganz
ganz schlimm nicht nur hier am
Rednerpult
für mich steht im Mittelpunkt die Frage
und dafür ist dieser Bericht auch da wie
kann auch Digitalisierung
geschlechtergerecht ausgestaltet werden
weil sich eben unter den Bedingungen des
digitalen Wandels Ungleichheiten noch
mal ganz neu zeigen es haben sehr viele
Vorrednerinnen heute schon von sich
gegeben und sie zeigen sich auch alle
anders wir haben schon den Schänder
paygap besprochen wir haben den gender
kehrgeb besprochen wo auch nur von ihnen
unfähige Dinge reingerufen werden
Motorölwechsel liebe Leute das glauben
Sie nicht selber was sie hier von sich
geben Herr ehrhorn aber ich möchte mich
gar nicht lange mit ihnen beschäftigen
weil es wirklich auch
verlorene liebesmühl ist ich möchte
einen weiteren Begriff einführen nämlich
den des Gender data gaps das bedeutet
eben dass anteilsmäßig ich weiß dass
Fremdwörter für Sie Glückssache sind
aber Sie können ja mal zuhören
anteilsmäßig gibt es mehr Daten
über Männer die gesammelt werden als
über Frauen
und es ist auch so dass diese nicht nach
Geschlechtern unterschieden werden und
es führt eben nicht wie man vielleicht
auf den ersten Blick glauben könnte
erstmal zu einer Gleichbehandlung
sondern eben zum Gegenteil weil
Geschlecht geschlechterspezifische
Verschiedenheiten die sie auf der einen
Seite immer rausholen die werden eben
ignoriert mit zum Teil verteilen
Konsequenzen das berühmteste Beispiel
ist sicherlich was jetzt nicht originär
digitales aber das beste Beispiel was
alle kennen ist nämlich das Thema der
Crashtest Dummies dass die immer
überwiegend männlich waren und daraus
eben die oh mein Gott sie ist vielen
Dank und der Bundestag diskutiert über
den Gleichstellungsbericht der
Bundesregierung denn die Bundesregierung
ist laut Grundgesetz dazu
verpflichtet die Durchsetzung der
Gleichberechtigung von Männern und
Frauen auch zu fördern und da gibt es
dann regelmäßig einen Bericht darüber
inwieweit der Start dieser Verantwortung
nachkommt und der Bericht über den jetzt
diskutiert wird der wurde schon im
vergangenen Sommer noch unter der
damaligen Bundesregierung vorgestellt
wird jetzt eben diskutiert er
konzentriert sich besonders auf die
Digitalisierung und inwieweit da eine
Gleichberechtigung von Männern und
Frauen stattgefunden hat oder eben das
kam hier in der Debatte raus schon eher
nicht und wir haben noch die Möglichkeit
zumindest zwei Redner von dieser Debatte
zu hören deswegen wollen wir jetzt
gleich ins Plenum geben um auch die
Opposition zu hören für diese spricht
Dorothee Bär die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Unionsfraktion
und deswegen wenn dann in Datensätzen
nur wenige Frauen vorkommen werden diese
vom Algorithmus als irrelevante
Abweichungen ignoriert und deswegen ist
es natürlich ein ganz ganz wichtiges
Thema an der Stelle weil Frauen
natürlich keine irrelevante Abweichung
sind
so sieht also der Algorithmus wenn man
nicht gegensteuern und deswegen brauchen
wir um diese Ungerechtigkeiten zu
beheben Veränderung auf mehreren Ebenen
beispielsweise bei der Gleichbehandlung
der Bewerberprofile schon viel darüber
gesprochen worden wo wir ansetzen müssen
in den Kindergärten in den Schulen aber
wir können es auch nicht nur den
Kindergärten und den Schulen überlassen
wir brauchen auch eine
nachmittagenangebote und ich möchte
jetzt mal einen großen Werbeblock hier
an dieser Stelle machen weil es wirklich
ein ganz ganz tolles Instrument ist was
wir in der letzten Legislaturperiode
leider nur singulär in Deutschland haben
einführen können ich gebe ganz offen zu
ich habe mir es anders vorgestellt in
der Hoffnung dass wir regieren dass wir
es flächendeckend in Deutschland
ausrollen aber ich möchte an die
Fraktionen der Ampel bitte mitgeben ob
sie sich mal anschauen können und
vielleicht umsetzen können wir haben
nämlich auf Bestreben der
Bundeskanzlerin ein sogenanntes
digitales Lernzentrum mit Namen Tumor in
Berlin hier eingeführt Tumor ist Zentrum
außerhalb der Schule freiwillig für
Kinder von 12 bis 18 Jahren ist es
dauerhaft es ist kostenlos es ist
regelmäßig und es ist gerade für Mädchen
ganz großartig weil es nennt sich
nämlich nicht nur digital sondern es
heißt zum Beispiel ein Center for
creative studies weil Sprache auch
wahnsinnig viel macht weil Kreativität
da fühlen sich Mädchen besser
angesprochen es ist leider immer noch so
dass es heißt oh Jungs machen mal Mathe
Mädchen sollen lieber Sprachen lernen
dann sagen wir ja Programmiersprachen
beispielsweise und ich kann alle
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nur ermuntern
sich das hier in Berlin mal anzuschauen
mein Wunsch wäre es dass wir es analog
der Mehrgenerationenhäuser in jedem
Landkreis in Deutschland in jeder
kreisfreien Stadt einrichten weil das
jeder wirklich vor Ort auch in seinen
Wahlkreisen gut brauchen könnte nicht
nur in Berlin wo es hervorragend
funktioniert oder würde ich Sie bitten
wirklich uns zu unterstützen an dieser
Stelle
Liebe Bundesregierung liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sie haben uns als Union an
Ihrer Seite wenn wir die
Handlungsempfehlungen der
Sachverständigenkommission ernst nehmen
wenn wir sie in konkrete
Umsetzungsschritte eben auch umsetzen
werden holen wir also die weiblichen
Crashtest damit weg vom Beifahrersitz
holen sie hinters Steuer bauen wir diese
Ungleichheiten ab und liebe Mädchen die
ihr heute alle zugeschaut habt liebe
Frauen ihr werdet an den Debatten sehen
ihr könnt mir die AFD wenn es nicht zu
eurem besten vielen Dank
Dorothee Bär war das der Bundestag
diskutiert über Gleichstellung von
Männern und Frauen und auch für die
cdu/csu ist das natürlich ein Thema denn
auch wenn man sich mal anschaut Julia
Klöckner hat gerade neulich den
Landesvorsitz in Rheinland-Pfalz
aufgegeben und so gibt es in der CDU
momentan und nur noch männliche
Landesvorsitzende wir kommen zur letzten
Rednerin schon in dieser Debatte das ist
Ariane Fischer für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Interessierte an den Bildschirmen in der
Pandemie waren die Menschen
durchschnittlich über zehn Stunden
täglich online aktuell sind es immer
noch mehr als sieben Stunden der dritte
Gleichstellungsbericht der
Bundesregierung fokussiert daher mit
gutem Grund auf die digitale Welt und
wie in der realen Welt sind auch in der
digitalen Welt Mädchen und Frauen im
Netz wesentlich häufiger Gewalt
ausgesetzt hier knüpfe ich an an die
Debatte zum Internationalen Frauentag
und möchte noch mal verstärken
Menschenrechte Frauenrechte es ist eins
die vorgestern vorgestellte
Kriminalitätsstatistik zeigt das Opfer
von Straftaten gegen sexuelle
Selbstbestimmung zu
92% Frauen und zu 50% unter 21 Jahren
alt sind die Fälle von sexuellen
Missbrauch von Kindern haben um 6,3%
zugenommen die Verbreitung
pornografischer Schriften um 88 Prozent
die virtuelle Welt wird dabei als Tatort
immer relevanter es gibt eine Vielzahl
von Formen von Gewalt an Frauen und
Mädchen im Netz Cybermobbing hate speech
bloßstellen und anschwärzen sogenanntes
docksing cyber-stocking Nötigung oder
Erpressung Verbreiten von Gerüchten und
Schmähungen Identitätsmissbrauch und
auch die offene Androhung von Gewalt
begünstigt durch die Anonymität des
Netzes und den räumlicher Distanz zum
Opfer das bedeutet das Netz ermächtigt
somit auch Feiglinge zum Täter zu werden
[Applaus]
unser Gehirn ist ein Wunderwerk es merkt
sich über sogenannte Spiegelneuronen
Erfahrungen und Gefühle damit wir in
einer künftigen Situation Muster
erkennen gewappnet sind schnell
reagieren können das soll unser
Überleben sichern doch das heranreifende
Gehirn eines unter 18-Jährigen
unterscheidet nicht zwischen wirklich
erlebten Szenen und virtuell erlebten
Erfahrungen und Emotionen ein Spiel ein
Film eine Diffamierung im Netz wird
genauso stark erlebt und genauso als
Wirklichkeit abgespeichert das Internet
prägt auf diese Weise direkt selbst und
Rollenbilder
welchen Einfluss hat das Internet auf
unsere Vorstellungswelten unendlich
viele Fotos selfies werden verschickt
vermeintlich verschönt durch Filter das
eigene Spiegelbild kann dann mit diesem
virtuellen ich nicht mehr mithalten und
das führt in der Realität zu Gefühlen
von Minderwertigkeit meist bei Frauen
dazu kommen neue Vorbilder
influencer:innen gecastet um durch
Schönheit Einfluss zu nehmen
Schönheit Erfolg und Ware werden somit
eine Einheit es entsteht ein auf
benutzen und verbrauchen ein auf
konsumieren ausgelegtes Menschen und
insbesondere Frauenbild
35 Prozent des Datenverkehrs im Internet
sind Zugriffe auf Pornos 9 von 10
Konsumenten sind Männer der Erstkonsum
ist gewöhnlich im Alter von 11 bis 12
Jahren
und 71 Prozent der 14 bis 17-Jährigen
gucken mehrfach wöchentlich
pornodarstellungen wir erinnern uns an
die Spiegelneuronen anhand dieser Bilder
prägen sich die Vorstellungen der jungen
Männer von Frauen und von Sex es prägt
sich ein Selbstbild von einem Mann der
das Recht hat alles was er will von der
Frau zu bekommen es sich nötigenfalls
auch zu nehmen diese Bilder von Frauen
als Objekt führen zur Enthemmung und zu
höherer Gewaltbereitschaft gegenüber
Frauen der Anteil polizeilich gemeldeter
Vergewaltigung und schwerer sexueller
Nötigung ist seit 2010 von 9,4 auf 11,9
Fälle pro 100.000 Einwohner gestiegen
wo kommt das her was ist zu tun
die Frauen Bundesfrauenministerium hat
2019 die bundesweite Initiative stärker
als Gewalt gestartet auf der
Online-Plattform aktiv gegen digitale
Gewalt gibt es gesammelte Informationen
über Formen digitaler Gewalt was dagegen
getan werden kann und wo es Hilfe für
Betroffene und Fachkräfte gibt es gilt
das Wissen zu stärken empfiehlt der
Gleichstellungsbericht bei Straftaten
soll erfasst werden ob digitale Medien
eine Rolle spielen
Fachberatungsstellen sollen ihre
Kompetenzen im Bereich
geschlechterbezogene digitale Gewalt auf
und ausbauen ein Schutzschirm könnte
Opfern unter anderem bei der Sicherung
von Beweismitteln dem Löschen von
hasskommentaren oder dem Schützen ihrer
Accounts helfen
zentral bleibt als Forderung die Reform
internationalen gesetzlichen Kinder und
Jugendmedienschutzes denn bis jetzt ist
es ein einziger Klick ich bin 18 um auf
der Pornoseite zu landen
die Kinder und Jugendlichen sollen
einerseits vor ungeeignetem Inhalt aber
sie insbesondere vor interaktionsrisiken
wie Mobbing sexualisierter anmacher
Hassrede aber auch vor Kontaktaufnahme
von Tätern geschützt werden
die Kombination aus Sensibilisierung
digital im Jugendschutz und einem
funktionierenden Hilfesystem haben wir
im Koalitionsvertrag als wichtige
Eckpfeiler des gewaltschutzes verankert
das Thema gehört auch einen runden Tisch
gegen Gewalt an Frauen und diesen wenn
wir im Mai fortsetzen
greifen wir darüber hinaus an der Wurzel
an das sind die gelebten Rollenbilder
und Vorbilder die Männer und Frauen
Mütter und Väter begeben aber lassen Sie
uns auch pädagogisch und in Kampagnen
Menschen und Rollenbilder prägen in
denen jeder Mensch gleich viel wert ist
und darüber hinaus alles was er oder sie
möchte sein kann lassen Sie uns was
und lassen sie uns noch was völlig
Verrücktes tun nämlich unser Grundgesetz
ernst zu nehmen indem wir die Würde des
Menschen die Würde der Frau wieder als
unantastbar anerkennen Frauenrechte sind
Menschenrechte in der realen und in der
virtuellen Welt vielen Dank
Ariane Fischer ruft ihr dazu aus etwas
völlig Verrücktes zu tun und das
Grundgesetz ernst zu nehmen die
Gleichberechtigung schreitet voran
allerdings gibt es doch immer noch
einige Lücken das ist zum Beispiel ganz
besonders deutlich beim Verdienst aber
es ist eben auch deutlich wenn man sich
die digitalwirtschaft anschaut wo Frauen
immer noch untere präsentiert sind nur
30 Prozent der Firmengründer sind
weiblich und es ist auch immer noch
deutlich dass künstliche Intelligenz
Algorithmen zum Beispiel Frauen mit
unter diskriminieren das trifft
allerdings nicht nur Frauen sondern auch
andere Minderheiten sogenannte
Minderheiten das unter anderem steht im
Bericht der Bundesregierung im
Gleichstellungsbericht im dritten der
wird jetzt überwiesen an die
entsprechenden Ausschüsse federführend
ist der Ausschuss für Familien Senioren
Frauen und Jugend und dann wird er dort
weiter diskutiert und kommt dann
irgendwann hier wieder in ins Plenum zur
weiteren wir kommen jetzt zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um das
kurzarbeitergeld- bzw die möglichen
Steuernachzahlungen die Linksfraktion
hat einen Antrag eingereicht in dem sie
fordert diese zu verhindern genaueres
werden jetzt die Linken erläutern ihr
Abgeordneter Christian Görke beginnt die
Debatte
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wie Sie wissen
haben wir tausende Beschäftigte gehabt
die in der Krise in Kurzarbeit sich
befunden haben und ich finde wenn diese
Beschäftigten oft schmerzhafte
Einschnitte hinnehmen mussten und jetzt
fette Steuernachzahlung aufgedrückt
bekommen das geht nicht und muss auch
hier diskutiert werden
Kurzarbeit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen heiß nicht nur Wiener Geld
Kurzarbeit heißt natürlich auch Angst
davor zu haben den Job zu verlieren
Angst seine Miete nicht bezahlen zu
können Angst mit der Familie nicht über
die Runden zu kommen und das letzte was
man dann noch in dieser
bescheidenen Situation gebrauchen kann
ist Post vom Finanzamt mit einer
besagten Nachzahlung warum diese
Nachzahlung nun das Kurzarbeitergeld ist
zwar steuerfrei aber im
Einkommensteuergesetz gibt es eine Tücke
den sogenannten Progressionsvorbehalt in
schreckliches Wort was heißt das um den
richtigen Steuersatz auf das zu
versteuernde Einkommen zu ermitteln wird
das Kurzarbeitergeld mit dem sonstigen
Einkommen dazugerechnet hier mal ein
gutes Beispiel aus der
Lebenswirklichkeit aus meinem Wahlkreis
in der Lausitz einer alleinstehende
Köchin hat letztes Jahr 40.000 Euro
verdien musste aber einige Monate in
Kurzarbeit und hat währenddessen 5000
Euro Kurzarbeitergeld bekommen während
diese 40.000 Euro ihr einziges Einkommen
lege ihr durchschnittlicher Steuersatz
bei
21,1%. die 5000 Euro Kurzarbeitergeld
werden aber bei der Berechnung der
Steuersatz des obendrauf geschlagen und
das Problem ist dass die Köchin also zu
wenig Einkommensteuer gezahlt hat muss
deshalb
652 Euro nachzahlen
652 Euro die ganz schön weh tun können
umdrehen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
müssen hunderttausende Kurzarbeiter
aufgrund dieser Sachlage ein
Einkommensteuererklärung abgeben das
haben viele auch nicht auf dem Schirm
der erste Brief vom Finanzamt ist dann
die Mahnung der zweite Brief ist dann
die schmerzhafte Nachzahlung zwei Briefe
die man sich ich glaube kneifen kann
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kollegen
ich habe die Regierung befragt über
welche Summe wir hier reden aus dem
progressionsvor ergeben sich allein für
2020 und 21 eine zusätzliche
Steuerbelastung und 3,5 Milliarden Euro
auf der anderen Seite sind diese 3,5
Milliarden Euro natürlich Einnahmen die
bzw von denjenigen hier gezahlt werden
die es unbedingt brauchen diese
Ungerechtigkeit zu stoppen und nebenbei
auch die
Lohnsteuerhilfeverein und Steuerberater
zu entlassen wollen wir das
Kurzarbeitergeld von diesen
Progressionsvorbehalt Tempo ja ausnehmen
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der FDP sehr geehrter herrbrand ich darf
Sie daran erinnern aber sie wissen es ja
selbst das haben sie im Jahr 2020 als
FDP-Fraktion hier in diesem Bundestag
beantragt wir haben damals zugestimmt
und heute stellen Sie den Finanzminister
und ich finde jetzt könnten Sie einfach
mal Nägel mit Köpfen machen sie als FDP
mit Bündnis 90 grün und den
Sozialdemokraten die ja auch im
Wahlkampf so oft die Entlastung vor
allen Dingen über die gesprochen haben
die es nötig haben die einen schmalen
Geldbeutel es wäre jetzt das mindeste
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Kurzarbeiter von ihren von diesen
Nachzahlungen auszunehmen und zu
schützen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
dirnd Gerke war das Sprecher für
Finanzpolitik der linken und übrigens
auch Interview Gast bei uns im morgen im
Phönix Doppel-Interview um 8 Uhr 45 vor
der Plenardebatte Dagmar André ist folgt
auf ihn sie ist SPD-Mitglied und als MdB
auch Mitglied des Finanzausschusses des
Deutschen Bundestags
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktion
Liebe linke grundsätzlich finde ich
Anträge die darauf abzielen die
Steuerlast bei kleinen und mittleren
Einkommen zu senken ja sehr charmant und
damit läuft man bei mir eigentlich
offene Türen ein was wir aber in der
SPD-Fraktion so gar nicht mögen ist eine
Ungerechtigkeit und diese
Ungerechtigkeit würden wir weiter
ausbauen wenn wir diesem Antrag folgen
würden wie der Kollege eben schon
richtig erklärt hat es gibt einen
Grundfreibetrag der liegt bei knapp
10.000 Euro bis zu dem wird gar keine
Einkommensteuer bezahlt mit steigendem
Einkommen steigt dann auch der
persönliche Steuersatz und zwar von
einem Eingangssteuersatz in Höhe von 14
Prozent bis zu einem Spitzensteuersatz
von maximal 45% für die besonders
reichen und das gilt ab rund 255.000
Euro zu versteuerndes Einkommen pro
Person
wer mehr verdient muss also auch mehr
Steuern zahlen und das ist vollkommen
richtig so
anstatt des Arbeitslohns oder auch
zusätzlich zum Arbeitslohn kann man aber
auch sogenannte Lohnersatzleistungen
beziehen das sind zum Beispiel
Elterngeld Mutterschaftsgeld Krankengeld
oder eben auch das im Antrag erwähnte
Kurzarbeitergeld diese
Lohnersatzleistungen sind steuerfrei
stehen aber unter dem völlig korrekten
Progressionsvorbehalt
das heißt für diese Lohnersatzleistungen
zahlt man zwar keine Einkommensteuer
aber diese steuerfreien Bezüge fließen
in die Berechnung des persönlichen
einkommenssteuersatzes mit ein also
zahlt man für den Arbeitslohn einen
höheren Steuersatz als man ohne
Kurzarbeitergeld gezahlt hätte und jetzt
hatte ich eigentlich auch ein Beispiel
das versuche ich jetzt schnell
anzupassen an die Köchin a und an die
Köchin B also wenn die Köchin a 40.000
Euro bei einer Vollzeittätigkeit im
Kalenderjahr an Einkünften erzielt hat
und darauf ihre Einkommenssteuern zahlt
und ich vergleiche damit jetzt die
Köchin B die neun Monate im Jahr
Vollzeit gearbeitet hat und drei Monate
in Kurzarbeit gearbeitet hat die hat
also 40.000 Euro Einkommen und 5000 Euro
Kurzarbeitergeld aus ihrem Beispiel
warum soll die jetzt die gleiche
Steuerlast tragen wie die Köchin die nur
40.000 Euro hatte Köchin 40.000 Euro
aussteuern Köchen 45.000 Euro mehr
Steuern
was soll denn dagegen sprechen dass eine
höhere Leistungsfähigkeit eben auch
höhere Steuern verursacht laut
Bundesverfassungsgericht nichts in der
Begründung einer übrigens unanfechtbaren
Entscheidung führt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht nämlich aus und
mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin möchte ich
zitieren der
Progressionsvorbehalt berücksichtigt das
Leistungsvermögen des Steuerpflichtigen
in der verfassungsrechtlich gebotenen
Weise es liegt auf der Hand das
Steuerpflichtige die im Kalenderjahr
neben eigenen Einkünften auch
Lohnersatzleistungen bezogen haben
wirtschaftlich leistungsfähiger sind als
steuerpflichtige die gleiche Einkünfte
ohne zusätzliche Lohnersatzleistungen
erzielt haben die Einbeziehung der
Lohnersatzleistungen zur Berechnung des
Steuersatzes begegnet daher keinen
verfassungsrechtlichen Bedenken zittert
Ende
warum die Linke den
Progressionsvorbehalt nur aus dem
Kurzarbeitergeld nehmen will nicht aber
aus den anderen Lohnersatzleistungen
wird im Antrag nicht erläutert diese
Antrag ist nicht neu und auch nicht
besser als all Ihre diesbezüglichen
Anträge zuvor wir empfänden das immer
noch als ungerecht und werden noch
wieder ablehnen in der
fortschrittskoalition der Ampel setzen
wir nämlich darauf mit vielen gerechten
und vor allen Dingen geeigneten
Maßnahmen insbesondere kleine und
mittlere Einkommen zu entlasten und das
werden meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
dieser Debatte sicherlich noch
ausführlich darlegen dafür lasse ich den
jetzt auf 35 Sekunden mehr Zeit vielen
Dank
das schauen wir mal ob die 35 Sekunden
bekommen als erstes
darf ich mal eben nur Fragen ist das
Mikrofon irgendwie auf den Boden
gefallen liegt da irgendwo jetzt noch
was rum
alles klar
dann erhält jetzt das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der Kollege Olaf
Gutting das Wort
[Applaus]
vielen
werde Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja die
letzten zwei Jahre waren für viele
Menschen in diesem Land in eine
herausfordernde Zeit wir haben in der
Regierung und im Parlament viel dafür
getan um die Belastungen für die
Menschen möglichst niedrig zu halten um
die Belastungen
abzumildern und eine Maßnahme davon war
dass wir das Kurzarbeitergeld so genutzt
haben dass Beschäftigte bei ihren
Unternehmen auch beschäftigt bleiben
konnten und diese Maßnahme wurde von uns
auch immer wieder verbessert sie wurde
verlängert und die haben zudem
ermöglicht dass Arbeitgeber auch
steuerfreie Zuschüsse auf das
Kurzarbeitergeld zahlen konnten
die aktuelle Ampelkoalition hat diese
sinnvollen Maßnahmen fortgeführt es
bleibt dabei dass die
Zugangsvoraussetzungen zum
Kurzarbeitergeld bis zum 30 Juni diesen
Jahres herabgesetzt bleiben und die
maximale Bezugsdauer für das
Kurzarbeitergeld wird befristet von 24
Monaten auf 28 Monate verlängert
nun das Kurzarbeitergeld wir haben es
vorhin schon gehört beträgt ja in der
Regel 60 bzw 67 Prozent der
Nettoentgeltdifferenz und das ist in
vielen Lohngruppen tatsächlich ein sehr
niedriger Auszahlungsbetrag erhöht sich
zwar ab dem vierten Monat dann auf 70
bzw 77 und ab dem 7 monat auf 80 bzw 87
Prozent der Nettoentgeltdifferenz aber
das ist natürlich nicht vergleichbar mit
dem normalen Bruttolohn
zusätzlich kann der Arbeitgeber diesen
Betrag noch mit einer steuerfreien
Zahlung erhöhen das wird auch oft von
den Arbeitgebern gemacht und man muss
diese Zahlen denke ich auch nennen denn
es geht ja hier am Ende um den Vergleich
zwischen den Nettobeträgen zwischen
normalem Arbeitnehmer und Kurzarbeiter
es geht also darum was hat man am Ende
in der Tasche und hier ist der Antrag
der Linken bei dem es ja faktisch um die
Abschaffung des
progressionsvorbehaltes für
Kurzarbeitergeld geht einfach falsch
gedacht die Linke will mit ihrem Antrag
ein anerkannten steuerlichen Grundsatz
aushebel nämlich die Besteuerung nach
der Leistungsfähigkeit und nur der
Progressionsvorbehalt stellt die
Besteuerung nach der Leistungsfähigkeit
sichern wer mehr verdient wer
leistungsfähiger ist da muss natürlich
höhere Steuern bezahlen als der der
weniger hat das ist richtig und das ist
korrekt mit ihrer Forderung nach der
Verhinderung von möglichen
Steuernachzahlungen und es ist ja nicht
überall der Fall aber mit ihrer
Forderung nach dieser Verhinderung
setzen sie von den Linken und dieses
Prinzip außer Kraft Tatsache ist die
Lohnersatzleistungen und eben damit auch
das Kurzarbeitergeld sind steuerfrei und
sie sind das und sie bleiben es auch es
wird ja lediglich zur Berechnung des
individuellen Steuersatzes diese
Lohnersatzleistung mit einbezogen und
wer Kurzarbeitergeld erhält der zahlt
für diesen Zeitraum in jedem Fall auch
weniger Steuern als beim Zug beim Bezug
des normalen bruttoarbeitslohns völlig
egal ob Köchin oder anderer Berufe es
ist so wer Kurzarbeitergeld bezieht
zahlt für diesen Zeitraum weniger
Steuern
würden jedoch Lohnersatzleistungen bei
der Berechnung des individuellen
Steuersatzes bezogen auf das gesamte
Jahreseinkommen und darum geht es ja
nicht berücksichtigt dann wäre das
gegenüber den übrigen Steuerpflichtigen
schlicht ungerecht es würde nicht nur
den vollständigen Steuerausfall für
diese Ersatzleistung bedeuten sondern
eben auch die Anwendung eines niedrigen
eben dann nicht mehr angemessenen
Steuersatzes für die übrigen Einkünfte
und das kann man tatsächlich nicht
befürworten wenn sie von den Linken die
mögliche Steuerbelastung für
Kurzarbeiter nur isoliert betrachten
dann verabschieden Sie sich von diesem
Prinzip der leistungsfähigen Besteuerung
der leistungsgerechten Besteuerung wenn
es ihnen
bei diesem Antrag denn um eine generelle
grundsätzliche Steuersenkung ginge dann
sind wir offen für Gespräche da können
wir gemeinsam gerne nach Lösungen suchen
aber sie wollen ja hier nur die
steuerliche Behandlung des
Kurzarbeitergeldes aussetzen und nicht
in Progressionsvorbehalt auch bei den
anderen
Lohnersatzleistungen wie zum Beispiel
Insolvenzgeld oder Arbeitslosengeld mit
abschaffen und da zeigt sich eben auch
dieser kurzfristige Effekt und da zeigt
sich eben auch der Unterschied zwischen
Oppositionsparteien weil bin Ihnen
dankbar dass nochmal erwähnt haben dass
die FDP als sie noch in der Opposition
war auch so ein ähnlichen Antrag
gestellt hat aber deshalb der
Unterschied wir sind auch in der
Opposition vernünftig wir sind auch in
der Opposition
verantwortungsbewusst und wir wechseln
hier nicht das Hemd von Populismus zu
Regierung sondern das ist der
Unterschied in der Opposition wir sind
auch hier in der Opposition eine
verantwortungsbewusste Fraktion
zusätzliche Belastungen für die Menschen
die schon unter den wirtschaftlichen
Folgen der Pandemie gelitten haben
sollen verhindert werden
selbstverständlich da gibt es überhaupt
kein Vertun das wollen wir auch aber wir
in der Union stehen eben auch für den
Grundsatz der Gleichmäßigkeit der
Besteuerung konkretisiert durch das
Leistungsfähigkeitsprinzip und das
werden wir hier nicht ausblenden aktive
arbeitnehmer dürfen im Ergebnis nicht
schlechter gestellt werden als Empfänger
von Ersatzleistungen und genau das wird
er mit ihrem Vorschlag in vielen Fällen
geschehen
Fazit wir halten fest unter dem
Gesichtspunkt einer gerechten
Besteuerung ist dem Einkommensteuerrecht
der Progressionsvorbehalt beim
Kurzarbeitergeld folgerichtig und erst
deswegen beizubehalten und ergo lehnen
wir deswegen ihren Antrag hier heute ab
so weit ist schon die Ankündigung von
Olaf guting cdu/csu zum Antrag der
Linksfraktion der hier debattiert wird
in der corona-pandemie hat die
Bundesregierung Sonderregelung
verabschiedet um den Zugang zu
Kurzarbeitergeld zu erleichtern und das
hat nun kann nun eben sich in der
Steuernachzahlung von
kurzarbeitergeld-empfängern bemerkbar
machen Olaf guting spricht jetzt für
pardon Sascha Müller spricht jetzt für
die grüne sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gäbe es das Kurzarbeitergeld nicht man
müsste es erfinden zahlreiche
Beschäftigungsverhältnisse konnten
während der corona-pandemie erhalten
bleiben eben weil es das
Kurzarbeitergeld gibt
auch ich war zu Anfang der
corona-pandemie in Kurzarbeit wenn auch
nicht wie in anderen Branchen zu 100
Prozent sondern nur mit reduzierter
Arbeitszeit für mich als Sportjournalist
gab es noch mal weniger zu tun als alle
Sportveranstaltungen abgesagt wurden die
kommt Bundesliga komplett aussetzen
musste die Werbeeinnahmen ausblieben und
in der Redaktion haben wir jetzt in
dieser Zeit genau darauf geachtet nicht
länger zu arbeiten als es die strengen
Regeln der Kurzarbeit erlaubt hatten was
bei einer journalistischen Tätigkeit gar
nicht so einfach ist Artikel müssen
recherchiert mit Informanten muss
gesprochen werden Interviews müssen
redigiert und autorisiert werden manches
geführte Interview konnte wie aus
anderen Ressorts weiß daher gar nicht
erscheinen nun insgesamt waren wir aber
vor unserem Beruf weiter ausüben zu
können dann in die demokratische
Öffentlichkeit braucht guten
Journalismus und auch Journalismus ist
systemrelevant
woran wir
[Applaus]
woran wir sicherlich seinerzeit
überhaupt nicht gedacht haben bei der
Progressionsvorbehalt
progressionsvorbehalte ist es bereits
gesagt worden beim Kurzarbeitergeld
bedeutet dass das Kurzarbeitergeld zwar
steuerfrei ist der gezahlte Betrag wird
aber zur Ermittlung des Steuersatzes auf
das eigentliche Erwerbseinkommen
herangezogen oft ergeben sich dadurch
Steuernachzahlungen ja aber das sind
nicht zwingend es könnte auch der
gegenteilige Effekt eintreten und
zugegeben emotional kann ich das
Anliegen des vorliegenden Antrags aus
der Fraktion der Linken durchaus
nachvollziehen natürlich ist es
ärgerlich wenn du zuerstaatliche Hilfe
bekommst und dann zeitverzögert über die
Einkommensteuer wieder was zurückzahlen
sollst obwohl das Kurzarbeitergeld doch
eigentlich steuerfrei ist hier könnte
der Eindruck einer gefühlten
Ungerechtigkeit entstehen
was aber was passieren würde wenn wir
dem vorliegenden Antrag folgen würden
wäre wir würden aus einer vielleicht
gefühlten Ungerechtigkeit eine
tatsächliche Ungerechtigkeit machen
entziffer 2 des vorliegenden
antragsstreichen sie Notwendigkeit nach
der Kurzarbeit eine
Einkommensteuererklärung abzugeben nur
für viele Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler bietet diese Notwendigkeit
dennoch erhalten zum Beispiel wenn Sie
den Antrag auf Lohnsteuerermäßigung
beantragt haben oder wenn Sie oder wenn
bei Verheirateten werden sie die
steuerklassenplan 5 gewählt haben die
ist für den Antrag genannten Zeitraum ja
noch gibt und wir Sie wissen wollen wir
als Ampel ja hier haben das ganze
[Applaus]
das ganze wird auch nicht besser wenn
Sie den progressionsverbal in Ziffer 1
des Antrags ganz streichen damit Hebeln
sie auch das ist schon gesagt worden
heben Sie den Grundsatz der Besteuerung
nach Leistungsfähigkeit aus und sie
verschärfen den Unterschied und damit
auch vielleicht eine weitere dann
gefühlte Ungerechtigkeit zwischen jedem
die als Arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmerhilfen in Form von
Kurzarbeit gehalten erhalten haben und
etwa zum Beispiel solo-selbstständigen
die ihre Überbrückung zur neustarthilfen
das in Antrags Instrument klar aber
dennoch nennigs so gar nicht nur mit
Progressionsvorbehalt sondern insgesamt
versteuern müssen und eine
nebenbei eine bessere Absicherung eine
Art von
kurzarbeitergeldversuchsabständige
werden es mal Überlegung wert aber das
nur am Rande nein
das rückwirkende Streichen des
Progressionsvorbehalts für die Jahre
2020 bis 22 wie im Antrag Bean vorgelegt
kommt für uns in der Tat nicht in Frage
die mit damit einhergehenden
Steuerentlastung wären zudem und darauf
kommt es heute gerade besonders an zu
dieser Zeit noch nicht einmal
zielgerichtet für mich und ich glaube
auch für meine damaligen Kolleginnen
Kollegen ebenso bei der sich ergebende
höhere Steuersatz kein wirkliches
Problem wenn sich Steuernachzahlungen
ergeben haben dann haben wir diese
Steuern gerne gezahlt damit der Staat
sich um die Hilfen für die wirklich
betroffenen Branchen und beispielsweise
auch im Kunst und Kulturschaffender
kümmern konnte
natürlich das haben sie aber leider
nicht gemacht ich sie hätten ja
Vorschläge machen können könnte man
darüber nachdenken wie diese eingangs
erwähnte gefühlte Ungerechtigkeit in der
Zukunft abzumildern wäre das ist
vielleicht auch eine Frage der
Kommunikation das sind mehrere
Möglichkeiten denkbar wenn sie hätten
beispielsweise ein Freibetrag ab dem der
Progressionsvorbehalt erst gilt
beantragen können haben sie leider nicht
was können wir wir kennen natürlich
nachdenken können was können wir in der
Zukunft ändern diese Besteuerung nach
Leistungsfähigkeit einerseits zu einer
halten und andererseits für die
Betroffenen die böse Überraschung einer
Steuernachzahlung zu vermeiden oder es
wird schwer gehen aber vielleicht
zumindest zum minimieren das tun sie mit
dem vorliegenden Antrag aber nicht und
deshalb können wir uns auch nicht mit
dem anfreunden aber wir freuen uns auf
die weitere Diskussion im Ausschuss ich
danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
als nächste Rednerin hält für die
afd-fraktion Gerrit may das Wort das
Wort Entschuldigung
und gerrituis ob Frau im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales für die AFD
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die Linken
sprechen in ihrem Antrag ein Problem an
dass ich in vielen Fällen staatlicher
Subventionspolitik wiederfindet sie ist
nicht ehrlich
genauer gesagt ihre Zahlen sind nicht
ehrlich Sophies fließt in vielen Fällen
gar nicht die angekündigte Subvention zu
machen Empfängern sondern eine
reduzierte Summe für den Fall des Corona
Kurzarbeitergeldes heißt das in der
Regel dass am Ende weniger als die
angekündigten 60 oder 67 Prozent das
vorherigen Einkommens im Portemonnaie
das kurzarbeiters Landen warum vielfach
gesagt schauen die Zahlung überliegt dem
sogenannten Progressionsvorbehalt sie
fließt zwar formal steuerfrei vom
staatempfänger erhöht aber sein übriges
die Steuern auf sein übriges Einkommen
so dass ihm am Ende netto weniger
verbleibt als angekündigt und nicht
genug dass weniger Geld bei ihm landet
er muss dafür auch noch Steuererklärung
abgeben was besonders ärgerlich ist wenn
er das zuvor nicht gebraucht hat schon
bei Bezug von nur 410 Euro
Kurzarbeitergeld wird sie dann fällig
die Steuererklärung was nicht nur beim
Empfänger des Geldes sondern auch in den
Finanzbehörden einen erheblichen
Mehraufwand auslöst die Regierung kann
diesen Mehraufwand zwar nicht genau
beziffern aber einige Millionen
zusätzliche Steuererklärungen dürfen es
schon sein und das erinnert fatal an
andere hoch bürokratische
Regierungsvorhaben wie zum Beispiel die
Grundrente die etwa 1,3 Millionen
Rentnern zugute kommen soll es ist sehr
erfreulich und es ist auch höchste Zeit
dass diese 1,3 Millionen Rentner die
Jahrzehnte lang Rentenbeiträge
eingezahlt haben einen Aufschlag auf
ihre viel zu niedrigen Renten erhalten
das dafür aber 1.000 neue Mitarbeiter in
der Rentenanstalt eingestellt werden
mussten zeigt dass auch die Grundrente
wie so vieles andere ein bürokratischer
Wurzel ist ein neuer Mitarbeiter für
1300 Grundrenten der Steuerzahler muss
ihr Gehalt die Nebenkosten Bürokosten
und die Verwaltungskosten Zahlen geht es
nicht auch mal einfacher oder muss jede
neue regierungsidee gleich immer in der
Arbeitsbeschaffungsprogramm ausatmen
aber einfache Lösung die man verstehen
und nachvollziehern ziehen kann mag die
Regierung offenbar nicht man muss ja
schon Steuerexperte sein und beim
Kurzarbeitergeld noch durchzublicken
aber egal ob man das versteht oder nicht
zahlen muss man immer und die
Größenordnung hat es in sich von den
12,6 Milliarden Euro ausgezahlten
Kurzarbeitergeld in 2020 flossen rund
2,1 Milliarden wieder an den Fiskus
zurück das sind knapp 17 Prozent die die
Kurzarbeiter im Schnitt weniger im
Portemonnaie hatten als angekündigt das
gleiche Spiel im Jahr 2021 8,1
Milliarden Euro wurden als
Kurzarbeitergeld gezahlt 1,4 Milliarden
Euro flossen als Steuern wieder an den
Fiskus zurück wieder gut 17 %. das ist
doch nicht fair die meisten Kurzarbeiter
hatten große Mühe mit den
corona-bedingten Einkommensverlust
zurechtzukommen und dann sollen am Ende
noch Steuern nachzahlen und das auch
noch bei der aktuellen Mehrbelastung
durch die hohe Inflation geht's noch wir
finden die Regierung sollte sich ehrlich
machen und dem Bürger grundsätzlich
sagen was Sache ist es wäre technisch
übrigens überhaupt nicht schwierig den
Kurzarbeitern die Steuererklärung
abzunehmen
das würde helfen dann würde den
Progressionsvorbehalt abschaffen die
Steuer die Kurzarbeiter mehr Geld und
die Behörden hätten weniger Arbeit das
wäre doch eine Lösung ähnliches gilt
übrigens auch für die Rentenempfänger
die zunehmend in die Besteuerung ihrer
Rente hineinrutschen viele von ihnen
haben in ihrem ganzen Berufsleben keine
Steuererklärung ausfertigen müssen aber
im Alter verlangt man es plötzlich von
ihnen am besten noch elektronisch oder
sollen sie sie dafür einen Steuerberater
sich nehmen auch hier gilt es dass es
technisch sehr wohl möglich wäre
Rentnern die aus ihrer Rente nichts
anderes zu versteuern haben dieses
Problem einfach in den Finanzbehörden
abzunehmen denn denen liegen alle
nötigen Daten vor
es wäre schön wenn man den Behörden auch
die Möglichkeit dazu einräumen würde
aber zurück zur faktischen Besteuerung
des kurzarbeitergelds Liebe linke wir
von der AFD können aus den dargelegten
Gründen sehr gut verstehen dass sie
diesen Antrag gestellt hat haben was wir
nicht verstehen können dass sie einen
fast gleichen lautenden Antrag von uns
den wir schon im Jahr 2020 und dann noch
einmal im Jahr 2021 gestellt haben
rundweg abgelehnt haben das war wohl
auch nicht ganz ehrlich danke
das Kurzarbeitergeld kann dazu führen
dass die übrigen steuerpflichtigen
Einkünfte der Beschäftigten höher
besteuert werden und das kann eben
bedeuten dass viele Menschen die in den
vergangenen Monaten aufgrund der
corona-pandemie Kurzarbeitergeld
empfangen haben nun mehr Steuern kriegen
darüber diskutiert der Bundestag sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
ja schon angedeutet worden dieser Antrag
ist mir nicht ganz unbekannt um es mal
ganz vorsichtig auszudrücken eigentlich
müsste man Lizenzgebühren dafür
verlangen denn es eins zu eins
abgeschrieben worden man könnte auch
ansatzweise mit Urheberrechtsklage
daraus machen aber es ist halt schlecht
gemacht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn gute Ideen sind halt nur dann gut
wenn sie auch zum richtigen Zeitpunkt
kommen und gute Ideen verlieren ihre
Wirkung auch dann wenn sie zum falschen
Zeitpunkt kommen sie kehren ihre Wirkung
gerade zu teilweise
und das werde ich Ihnen gleich erläutern
aber auch ich komme nicht umhin kurz
darauf zu rückzukommen was der
Progressionsvorbehalt eigentlich ist wir
haben halt in Deutschland Einkünfte die
sind steuerfrei und andere die sind
steuerpflichtig und in der Mitte liegen
die die den Progressionsvorbehalt
unterliegen das wird das ist ja schon
erläutert worden da wird halt der da
werden die Einkünfte berücksichtigt um
den Steuersatz zu ermitteln und da es in
den meisten Fällen diesbezüglich auch zu
Nachzahlungen kommt nicht in allen aber
in den meisten Fällen zu Nachzahlung
kommt hat der Gesetzgeber auch
vorgesorgt und hat gleich für eine
Erklärungspflicht für diese Dinge für
diese Fälle gesorgt meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ich will das nicht nur
aus formalen Gründen ablehnen Herr
Kollege Goerke sondern da gibt es
wirklich jetzt was Ihren Antrag angeht
inhaltlich handfeste Gründe dafür
im Ursprung hatte dieser Antrag in 2020
eine sehr nachvollziehbare und gute
Agenda man konnte sich entscheiden der
Gesetzgeber ist frei zu entscheiden
darüber ob er Einkünfte steuerfrei
stellt ob er Einkünfte steuerpflichtig
stellt oder ob er Einkünfte den
professionsvorbehalt unterwirft damals
hat die große Koalition auf unseren
Antrag hin diesen unseren Antrag
abgelehnt und hat gesagt ja wir wollen
daran nichts ändern Besteuerung nach der
Leistungsfähigkeit etc wir hätten uns
damals dafür entschieden entscheiden
können diesen coronabedingten
provisionsvorbehalt auszusetzen auch die
Erklärungspflicht auszusetzen es wäre
eine große Unterstützung seiner Zeit für
die Menschen gewesen es wäre auch eine
Unterstützung für die Verwaltung gewesen
nun aber in 2022 ist es eigentlich zu
spät es ist nicht eigentlich zu spät es
ist zu spät diesen Fehler der damaligen
großen Koalition zu beheben
es führt gerade zu zu neuen
Ungerechtigkeiten weil sie gleiche
Sachverhalte zu für die Zukunft von der
Vergangenheit ungleich behandelt wurde
werden und Sie werden nicht wie sie in
ihrem Antrag schreiben für Bürokratie
Entlastung sorgen sie werden sogar für
deutlich mehr Bürokratie Sorgen denn wir
wollen sie das denn in der Praxis
handhaben das müssten Sie mir mal
erläutern wenn sie jetzt ich sag mal die
20er Erklärungen die sind ja schon
längstens abgegeben jedenfalls in den
meisten Fällen auch die 21er Fälle die
müssten ja dann
rückwirkend korrigiert werden wollen sie
das nur auf Antrag machen soll das die
Verwaltung von Amts wegen machen das
sind alles Fragen ist das rechtlich
überhaupt noch möglich
interessiert sie vermutlich gar nicht ob
das rechtlich möglich ist also das ist
in der Tat dieses Prozedere das ist
einfach zu kompliziert und führt zu
einer aus meiner Sicht erheblichen
Mehrarbeit für die Verwaltung wenn jetzt
die 20er und auch 25er Fälle wieder
aufgerollt werden müssen deshalb denke
ich jetzt dieser Antrag überhaupt nicht
durchdacht
jedenfalls für die Vergangenheit und
ehrlich gesagt bin ich immer noch da am
überlegen ob es eher für mich spricht
dass sie diesen Antrag abgeschrieben
haben oder ob es eben gegen sie spricht
dass sie den so unreflektiert übernommen
haben auch aus der Vergangenheit
herzlichen Dank
Markus herbrandt der finanzpolitische
Sprecher der FDP und ich habe es vorhin
schon bei Christian Görke gesagt und so
das trifft auch auch Markus Herbrand zu
morgen wird er bei dem Phönix
Doppel-Interview sein ab 8 Uhr unter
anderem zum
corona-steuerhilfegesetz hier aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag
basari spricht jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion und das ist seine erste
Rede die er hier im Plenarsaal hält
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren dem
Antrag der Fraktion DIE LINKE können wir
nicht zustimmen weil er wie schon
verschiedene Rednerinnen und Redner hier
ausgeführt haben von seiner Systematik
her unstimmig ist und als
Einzelforderung unausgegoren ist damit
ist Ihr Antrag das glatte Gegenteil von
der überaus zielgerichteten und
wirksamen wirtschaftsarbeits- und
Sozialpolitik die wir seit zwei Jahren
zur Eindämmung dieser corona-krise
einsetzen und nicht zuletzt von der SPD
der Regierungsverantwortung
vorangetrieben wurde und sich jetzt ganz
konkret in der Arbeit dieser
Ampelkoalition niederschlägt
ich versuche jedem Antrag naja fast
jedem Antrag den ich ablehne möglichst
etwas Positives abzugewinnen und ich
werde auch bei ihnen fündig ganz zu
Beginn ihres Antrags finden sich ja
durchaus anerkennende Worte für unsere
Politik zur corona-krisenbewältigung sie
haben Recht dass das Modell der
Kurzarbeit dass wir schon bei der
Wirtschafts- und Finanzkrise 2008/2009
erfolgreich erprobt haben mit dem
damaligen Arbeitsminister Olaf Scholz
und jetzt wieder mit Hubertus Heil
unsere Gesellschaft verstärken Job und
Wohlstandsverlusten bewahrt hat und eine
Spitze bis zu zwei Millionen Jobs
gerettet hat Herr Müller hat es
ausgeführt ganz lebensnah welche
Branchen davon betroffen waren das
Instrument der Kurzarbeit des alleine in
meiner Bundesagentur Region K2 Rastatt
über 9.000 Unternehmen in der Spitze
genutzt haben
und die steuerfreie Lohnersatzleistung
Kurzarbeitergeld waren und sind ein ganz
zentraler Baustein und Mark Erreichen
unserer Krisenpolitik die international
Anerkennung und Nachahmer gefunden hat
und die unsere Volkswirtschaft bis heute
stabilisiert
Millionen von Beschäftigten haben bisher
vom Kurzarbeitergeld profitiert dass wir
immer wieder in den letzten zwei Jahren
Herr Göttinger das glaube ich ausgeführt
optimiert haben mit einem ausfallvolumen
von über 42 Milliarden Euro und die
aktuelle Krisenlage die sich
verschärften in lieferkettenprobleme die
enorm wirtschaftlichen Folgen des
russischen Angriffskrieges in der
Ukraine zeigen dass das Kurzarbeitergeld
eine ganz wichtige Leistung ist die
dringend gebraucht wird
aber damit bei dieser langen Debatte zu
ihrem Antrag nicht der Eindruck verfängt
dass wir uns im Zuge von Maßnahmen zu
Stabilisierung und Entlastung nur einzig
und allein auf das Kurzarbeitergeld
konzentrieren müssten helfe ich Ihnen
gerne auf die Sprünge wie umfassend das
anti-management dieser letzten zwei
Jahre war und wie umfassend ist vor
allen Dingen noch werden wird wir
bringen Millionen von Beschäftigten und
Unternehmen durch viele durchdachte
Maßnahmen durch diese Krise so haben
zehntausende antragsstände Unternehmen
profitiert
181 Milliarden Euro die im übrigen voll
zu versteuern sind in der Regel hat der
Staat während der Pandemie an
Unternehmen ausgezahlt als sofort
überbrückungs- oder neustarthilfen über
KfW-Kredite und in
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond für große
Unternehmen neben der Kurzarbeit haben
genau diese Maßnahmen zum Erhalt von
Arbeitsplätzen und zur Vermeidung von
Insolvenzen beigetragen im Jahr 2021 gab
es knapp 14.000 Insolvenzen das waren
zwölf Prozent weniger als im Vorjahr und
25 Prozent unter Vorkrisenniveau hinzu
kommen konjunkturstützende Maßnahmen die
wir ganz konkret noch in dieser Woche in
erster Lesung beim corona-steuer
hilfe-gesetz und beim
Steuerentlastungsgesetz im Bundestag
beraten werden auch die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger entlasten wir in diesem Jahr mit
einer Vielzahl von konkreten Maßnahmen
in Bereichen Mobilität Energie und
Steuernachlässe mit einem Volumen von
mehr als 30 Milliarden Euro das genau
kommt Familien und Beschäftigten die
Ihnen ja auch so wichtig sind als linke
Fraktion enorm zugute Liebe
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das alles
zeigt die Ampelkoalition handelt
umfassen und entschlossen um unser Land
gut durch die aktuellen Krisen zu führen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer und
Unternehmen können sich sicher sein dass
diese Koalition zu zielgenauen Maßnahmen
greift die entlasten Jobs und Wohlstand
sichern sie können sich auf die
Ampelkoalition verlassen wir haben eine
abgestimmte Strategie das ist weitaus
wichtiger als das ganz kleine Karo dass
die Linke hier versucht mit ihrem Antrag
zu spielen wir werden diesen Antrag
guten Gewissens ablehnen und unsere
Arbeit einfach weitermachen vielen Dank
das Projekt Casa Mavi hier an für die
SPD-Fraktion auf ihrem vollkommen er
Michael Meister Mitglied der
cdu/csu-fraktion und er sitzt im
Finanzausschuss hier in der Debatte zum
Antrag der Linksfraktion mit dem Titel
Steuernachzahlung für kurzarbeiterinnen
und Kurzarbeiter verhindern
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es kotzt die Kurzarbeit und das
Kurzarbeitergeld ist eigentlich ein
etabliertes instrument was wir in
Deutschland haben um Beschäftigung bei
ja Schwankungen in der Nachfrage zu
stabilisieren
und deshalb ist es auch ein dauerhaftes
instrument was wir in diesem Land haben
allerdings haben wir bei der Finanzkrise
und jetzt auch in der corona-pandemie
die Zugangsregeln vereinfacht und wir
haben die Bezugszeiten deutlich
erweitert um damit sozusagen diesem
Schock der auf den Arbeitsmarkt gegangen
ist sozusagen entgegenzuwirken und zu
einer Stabilisierung der Beschäftigten
beizutragen und ich glaube das war eine
richtige Entscheidung
jetzt muss man sehen
dass dieses keine Wohltat des Staates
ist sondern das Kurzarbeitergeld wird
finanziert durch Beiträge von
Arbeitnehmern und Arbeitgebern und
deshalb will ich an der Stelle mal daran
erinnern wenn jetzt Anfang diesen Monats
fast alle Maßnahmen im Zusammenhang mit
Corona ausgelaufen sind
dass wir auch mal darüber nachdenken
müssen ob an der Stelle aus fairn ist
Gründen zu denen hin die das ganze
bezahlen nämlich die Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitgeber die Beiträge entrichten wer
dann auch über die Frage Auslaufen der
Sonderregelungen dringend nachdenken
müssen glaubt das ist dringend geboten
aus als Fairness gegenüber denen die das
ganze bezahlen der Antrag der hier
gestellt wird von der Fraktion DIE LINKE
bezieht sich jetzt auf den
Progressionsvorbehalt
nach Paragraph 32b Einkommensteuergesetz
und bezieht sich ausschließlich auf die
Jahre 2020 bis 22 ich habe eben eingangs
gesagt es Kurzarbeitergeld gibt es immer
gegen nur die Sonderregelungen Zugang
und Dauer sind befristet und deshalb
müssen sie eigentlich denkt logisch wenn
sie so einen Antrag stellen den Antrag
dauerhaft stellen das tun sie
ausdrücklich nicht und deshalb ist es
wie man sieht ziemliche Unsinn zum
zweiten
sie stellen steuerpolitische Grundsätze
hier in Frage das kann man tun man kann
über die Frage ob etwas steuerpflichtig